bonjour à tous il est 15h c'est le
retour de ce Grand Direct autour de la
réforme des retraites que vous suivez
sur l'antenne depuis Xena depuis
maintenant 8 jours nous sommes au
lendemain effectivement du vote autour
de l'article 7 sur le décalage de l'âge
de départ à la retraite et au lendemain
de cette adoption le Sénat a attaqué la
suite des articles car il faut aller
vite si les sénateurs veulent finir
l'examen des 20 articles au total d'ici
dimanche minuit pour m'accompagner toute
cette après-midi et se Grand Direct on
retrouve alexandre Poussin en tribune de
presse bonjour à vous Alexandre bonjour
Quentin quelle est ma compagnie
effectivement aujourd'hui vous avez
suivi attentivement tous les débats de
ce matin que contient l'article 8 et
bien Quentin cet article 8 de la réforme
des retraites il est très important car
il concerne les départs anticipés à la
retraite avec notamment des mesures pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
tous ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 20 ans pourront partir avant cet
âge légal de départ qui a été reporté à
64 ans avec différentes bornes de d'âge
en fonction des durées de carrière des
personnes concernées à cette réforme des
retraites elle prévoit également des
parents anticipées pour les travailleurs
handicapés qui pourront toujours partir
à 55 ans alors que vos modifier la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
dans cette article 8 elle est sénateurs
ils sont plutôt favorables les sénateurs
de la droite sénatoriale mais ils
veulent maintenir un départ anticipé à
60 ans pour les travailleurs déclarés en
incapacité permanente et puis la
majorité des droits de sénatoriales et
également très attachée à un amendement
qui va être discuté cet après-midi et
qui prévoit une surcote des pensions de
retraite des maires de famille sur les
trimestres cotisés à partir de 63 ans
donc voilà ça c'est vraiment
l'amendement qui va être discuté cet
après-midi Alexandre on sait que depuis
deux jours maintenant les débats sont
très vifs entre la droite et la gauche
il y a toujours de fortes tensions dans
l'hémicycle où on s'accuse mutuellement
de ne pas vouloir débattre sur le fond
c'est encore le cas autour de un article
8 n'est-ce pas effectivement ça a été
très tendu ce matin allez débats ont
commencé sur les chapeaux de roue car
les sénateurs devaient examiner
l'amendement de Bruno Retailleau le
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat qui proposent et bien d'accélérer
la suppression de certains régimes
spéciaux de retraite une suppression qui
est prévue par cette réforme des
retraites écoute théâtre ce matin la
droite sénatoriale a annoncé vouloir
reporter l'examen de cet amendement à
plus tard dans ce texte de la réforme de
retraite alors la gauche sénatoriale a
crié au refus de débattre de la part des
sénateurs de droite et puis de son côté
Bruno Retailleau à accusé à la gauche
d'alimenter un climat social tendu alors
qu'il y a également des actions
d'opposants à cette réforme des coupures
d'électricité qui touchent des
établissements de santé notamment et
puis des permanences d'élus et puis une
fois que l'examen de cet amendement a
été reporté les débats ont continué
c'était plutôt calme jusqu'à l'arrivée à
ce fameux article 8 la gauche avait
préparé des centaines d'amendements de
suppression de cet article 8 et la
droite sénatoriale à souhaiter accélérer
les débats pour arriver directement au
débat sur l'amendement du rapporteur LR
René Paul Savary qui prévoit cette
surcote des pensions de retraite des
maires de famille et si jamais c'est
amendement est adopté que l'article 8 é
rectifié et bien ça pourrait faire
tomber de nombreux amendements de la
gauche et bien justement c'est René Paul
Savary qui s'exprime en ce moment dans
l'hémicycle le retour au direct dans les
débats
une surcote de 5% sur le plan du montant
est effectivement équivalent à une année
de retraite puisque la surcote porte sur
un
une disposition actuelle qui fait qu'on
estime qu'une durée moyenne de retraite
étant de 20 ans quand vous avez 5 % de
façon complémentaire vous avez les 100%
autour de 20 ans ça correspond à une
année de départ anticipé sauf sauf que
il y a d'un côté ces 5% qui sont viagés
répartis sur 20 ans ce qui est déjà
signifiécatif que de l'autre côté vous
perdriez directement ça veut dire que
vous en prenant de façon anticiper la
carrière vous avez un coût qui tombe
directement sur le sur le système de
retraite que cette mesure qu'on leur dit
insuffisante et oui je partage c'est
jamais suffisant peut-être que on peut
éventuellement l'élargir et ça a été
proposé à travers un amendement
l'élargir jusque 62 ans non à 62 dans le
régime actuel vous n'avez pas de surcote
puisque pour aller la surcote il faut
aller non seulement avoir son taux plein
mais aller au-delà de l'âge légal donc
on peut avoir une surcote dans le régime
actuel à partir de 62 ans et un
trimestre qui correspond à 1,25 % de
surcôte que vous avez tout au long de
votre carrière et là jusque 3 4
trimestres nous avons contingenté la
mesure à 4 trimestres de façon à ce que
le coût soit raisonnable mais si
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
qu'on aille un peu plus loin pour rester
dans le droit actuel et gagner encore
donc trois trimestres ne vous gênez pas
pour donner un avis favorable parce que
à ce moment-là on dépassera le droit
actuel donc il me faut votre
autorisation et franchement je
préférerais qu'on fasse un effort pour
les maires de famille plutôt que par des
mesures d'âge qui ratent leur cible mais
on aura l'occasion d'en discuter tout à
l'heure c'est un avis strictement
personnel que je me permets de vous dire
en tout cas notre mesure pas suffisante
touchera néanmoins 30% des femmes d'une
génération 30% quand même d'une
génération qui liquide une génération
par rapport au nombre de femmes qui
liquide leur retraite sur une génération
ça me paraît significative ça coûte
touche quand même 130 000 personnes donc
c'est un dispositif qui mérite toute
votre attention et qui compte tenu des
explications que je vous ai donné que
j'espère le plus clair possible nous
permet de vous proposer de prendre cette
mesure et pas les autres que les sont
traduites à travers vos sous amendements
parce que c'est celle qui correspond le
plus aux préoccupations de nos maires de
famille et qui conduisent je le répète
une fois encore mais des fois on peut
être répétitif dans ce débat à une
diminution des niveaux de pension entre
les hommes et les femmes je vous
remercie merci la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
me suis exprimé longuement à la fin de
la discussion générale sur l'article
donc comme je l'avais promis je vais
être bref le gouvernement soutient
l'amendement adopté par la commission
des affaires sociales parce qu'il a ce
double mérite à la fin de permettre le
maintien d'un avantage de temps sous
forme de majoration durée de
d'affiliation régime pour les femmes et
plus largement les assurés bénéficiant
de trimestres dit familiaux qui n'ont
pas une carrière complète au moment de
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et parce
qu'il permet une surcote pour celles qui
au contraire ont atteint la durée
d'affiliation requise à 63 ans et alors
qu'il restera 4 trimestres à travailler
donc c'est un avis favorable c'est un
avis défavorable pour les mêmes raisons
que c'est l'évoquée par monsieur le
rapporteur y compris les questions
d'équilibre budgétaire pour l'ensemble
des sous amendements je fais juste une
parenthèse pour dire que un certain
nombre d'interventions ont souligné la
difficulté qui subsiste quand elle est à
la différence de niveau de pension entre
les hommes et les femmes c'est
évidemment à la fois un constat et un
regret qui sont partagés mais la réalité
de la solution
merci alors pour explication de vote à
mes précédentes rossignol
d'accord mais
oui Vivi on va faire on va faire
globalement voilà merci madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup alors je vais
faire un explication de votre sur
l'amendement Savary avant j'inverse un
peu d'abord pour dire une chose c'est
que cet amendement c'est l'ambulance qui
suit l'offensif terrestre contre la
retraite à 62 ans et que bien entendu
comme on est respectueux des conventions
on ne va pas tirer sur l'ambulance c'est
pour ça que nous voterons cet amendement
ce qui me concerne je voterai pour
autant j'ai quelques remarques à faire
sur cet amendement la première concerne
un peu les sous amendements monsieur
rapporteur on pourrait faire et les
majorations de durée d'assurance et
l'augmentation de et la surcote l'un
n'est pas contradictoire de l'autre
quand on a 35% des cas de rémunération
entre les femmes et les hommes on
pourrait aussi augmenter spécifiquement
les pensions des femmes
première remarque deuxième remarque
ça concerne la nature des écarts de
salaire entre les écarts de pension
entre les hommes et les femmes il y a
deux facteurs premiers facteurs c'est
effectivement les carrières trouées
deuxième facteur c'est la faiblesse des
rémunérations des femmes pendant toute
leur durée d'activité qui impactent
aussi leur montant de pension et de ce
point de vue là votre amendement qui est
spécifiquement réservé aux maires de
famille
fait l'impasse sur les inégalités
salariales sur le fait que il n'y a pas
que les maires de famille
malheureusement qui souffrent de
rémunération insuffisante et
inégalitaire les femmes qui n'ont pas
d'enfants sont dans la même situation
l'écart résiduel de rémunération entre
les femmes et les hommes et de 9%
indépendamment des carrières celui qui
reste à post égal travailler égal
diplôme égal donc en excluant toutes les
femmes qui ne sont pas mère de famille
de cet amendement vous ne répondez pas à
l'écart de rémunération spécifique entre
les femmes et les hommes qui impactent
également la carrière des femmes qui ne
sont pas mère de famille enfin je ne
crois pas seulement cette mesure est
utile mais je j'ai un doute sur sa
dimension nataliste pour tout vous dire
je connais peu de jeunes femmes qui a
28-30 ans se demande si au moment où
elle veut le mettre un bébé en route
elles auront ou non une surcote ce
qu'elles veulent savoir c'est c'est pour
travailler élever leurs enfants avoir un
logement
avoir une crèche et ne pas souffrir dans
leur carrière du fait d'être mère de
famille merci la parole est à Madame A
poursu poli
ah d'accord ok merci
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues j'ai eu à au moins à deux
reprises l'occasion de m'exprimer par
rapport à cet amendement en réalité et à
la logique politique qu'il suit à la
fois quand j'ai présenté pour mon groupe
la motion référendaire et encore et
encore hier en fait ce qui n'est pas
juste et nous l'avons dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est le fait d'allonger l'âge
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans qui
pénalise plus particulièrement les
femmes toutes les femmes qu'elles soient
maire de famille ou pas mère de famille
les explications vous les a donné par
rapport aux carrières hachées par
rapport aux inégalités salariales mais
vous n'avez pas voulu les entendre que
ce soit aux banc du gouvernement ou au
niveau de nos de notre rapporteur nous
avons eu également nous nous avions fait
un amendement global pour réécrire
cette cette amendement finalement il a
été il a été rejeté donc vous ne en rien
la problématique des femmes qui ont des
petites des carrières hachées des petits
des petits salaires et qui vont être
pénalisés par cette elles sont les
grandes perdantes je les dis encore hier
lors de la question d'actualité même si
le ministre essaye de démontrer le
contraire alors en réalité évidemment
comme nos collègues socialistes comme
c'est un petit plus un petit mieux pour
quelques femmes cet amendement on va le
voter mais c'est vraiment totalement
insuffisant et ça ne répond pas à la
demande des femmes et puis moi je
voudrais vous donner la proposition des
communistes qui régleraient cette cette
question de surcote nous vous le montant
du congé parental d'éducation en fait on
est pour qu'il soit équivalent à 100% du
salaire ce qui éviterait justement la
question de la surcotte il ne me dites
pas que vous n'avez pas l'argent on a
plein de solutions pour financer ces
mesures mais vous les refusez alors en
attendant que vous réfléchissiez et bien
on va voter ce petit pas très petit mais
c'est faut commencer par quelque chose
merci beaucoup madame ponce
oui merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais dire monsieur le ministre
que tout à l'heure il a dit quelque
chose et il a raison il a dit
l'effacement enfin la neutralisation des
trimestres enfants n'est pas que due à
la logement d'âge il est dû aussi au
fait que les femmes travaillent plus
c'est l'effet générationnels les faits
noria il a raison à deux tiers un tiers
parce que un tiers effectivement des
trimestres ont été effacés par la loi
2010 pour 2017 ça va être encore plus
important je pense nous vous l'avons dit
000 femmes par génération aujourd'hui
partent à 62 ans et de toute façon font
ce choix elles ont donc les deux
conditions
et elles partent à taux plein donc cette
trimestre des trimestres enfants vont
tous là devenir des trimestres
travaillés monsieur le rapporteur la
surcote effectivement vous l'avez dit
c'est une neutralité
actuariale mais l'esprit de la surcote
c'est le volontariat
aujourd'hui pour ces femmes si vous
voulez à 62 ans elle pouvait travailler
encore deux ans et on l'a dit elles
auraient eu 10% 10% de surcotte 10% de
surcotes c'est parce que effectivement
leur patrimoine retraite c'était neutre
sur leur patrimoine retraite c'est à
dire que les deux ans qu'elle n'avaient
pas elles ne gagnerait par la surcotte
aujourd'hui vous leur en donner la
moitié je parle des 120 000 femmes en
leur en donnant la moitié vous faites
baisser le patrimoine retraite de ces
femmes de ces femmes qui utilisaient
majoritairement leur trimestre d'enfant
nous vous l'avons dit les mesures d'âge
sont anti redistributives elles
accroissent les inégalités
toutefois et vous préférez ça
effectivement au départ parce que
effectivement vous voulez qu'on produise
plus et vous voulez surtout respecter le
pack de stabilité à court terme et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur c'est
pas pareil en termes de termes de court
terme donc c'est pour ça que vous
préférez la surcote donc tout comme mes
collègues comme ça limite c'est une
mesure une des mesures de tes nations de
la brutalité de la réforme bien entendu
nous la voterons avec tout toutes ces
considérations
merci madame la Présidente oui
effectivement cette amendement c'est une
petite mesure de compensation que vous
avez négocié mais qui ne va pas annuler
la brutalité de cette loi vous avez au
moins le mérite de la cohérence avec cet
article 8 parce que dans la casse de
notre service de notre système de
solidarité avec cette volonté que vous
avez de faire travailler plus deux ans
de plus nos concitoyens quel que soit
leur difficulté et la durée de leur
carrière il y aura peut-être d'autres
mesures de compensation votées mais
quand même
vouloir au départ faire retravailler
deux ans de plus des travailleurs qui
sont déclarés inapte au travail les
allocataires de la hache les
accolocataires de la location de
cessation anticipées d'activité les
travailleurs ayant une carrière longue
les travailleurs handicapés les
travailleurs qui ont une incapacité
permanente à la suite d'un accident de
travail ou une maladie professionnelle
les fonctionnaires handicapés les
fonctionnaires enfin je vais pas en
rajouter on est vraiment là dans cette
volonté un moment donné dans le
brutalité de faire travailler plus les
personnes les plus fragiles et les plus
précaires bon bien évidemment les femmes
ont la tous dit ici sont les grandes
perdantes de cela et je le redis ce
n'est pas cette petite mesure qui va
améliorer leur retraite ce que je
voulais dire quand même en accord avec
mes collègues c'est que nous le voterons
quand même il vaut mieux tenir que
courir
merci Madame alors monsieur
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre alors nous voterons cette
amendement pour des motifs d'équilibre
des principes de d'équilibre de justice
et puis aussi de valeurs
parce que évidemment il faut plus de
justice vis-à-vis des femmes il y a une
injustice ça a été dit au niveau de la
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes 10% à salaire à fonction égale ou
à diplôme égal et c'est insupportable
mais on peut pas tout attendre non plus
du du système de retraite je veux le
dire au collègue se soucier de cette
injustice à l'occasion d'une réforme de
du système de retraite c'est juste mais
on s'en est pas toujours soucier autant
et notamment à l'occasion de la réforme
Touraine sans ouvrir à nouveau la
polémique tout de même je veux le
signaler donc on peut pas tout attendre
de cette de cette réforme nous on aurait
même voulu peut-être aller plus loin
mais on prend effectivement
peut-être amendement et puis on a retiré
nos amendements pour que nous allions au
bout de cette discussion et nous y
tenons beaucoup et c'est pour nous
l'essentiel d'aller au bout de cette
discussion et puis pour des questions
d'équilibre aussi j'ai entendu madame
Vogel souvent je ne suis pas d'accord
avec elle mais je reconnais la
construction de de son argumentation
mais avec un système de retraite par
répartition il est tout à fait
indispensable légitime de s'occuper de
de démographie et de la dimension d'un
nataliste elle est intrinsèque au
système de répartition et enfin un
dernier mot sur la valeur pour nous la
famille ça n'est pas une j'ai entendu
tout ça tout à l'heure ça n'est ni une
idéologie ni une doctrine c'est une
valeur mes chers collègues la famille ni
une doctrine ni délogie inéditologie
mais une valeur et et pour nous
mère de famille ça n'est pas un gros mot
père de famille ça n'est pas un gros mot
et la valeur c'est même une valeur
essentielle une cellule de base de la
société comme disait Victor Hugo la
famille c'est la plus solide des
forteresses je vous remercie
merci Monsieur mouillé
monsieur mouillé
monsieur Cabanel
merci Madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur ministre Richard collègue donc
pour une fois on prend pas la parole
souvent parce que dans mon groupe chacun
est libre de son vote et pour une fois
nous avons donc tous voté cet amendement
pour rendre la justice donc aux femmes
qui ont une carrière hachée mais je vais
profiter de la parole pour expliquer
donc ici quels sont notre quel est notre
frustration dans le groupe de voir ce
débat se dérouler comme il se déroule on
aimerait mieux qu'il y ait un véritable
débat ce qu'il me semble ne pas y avoir
alors certains reprochent à la majorité
sénatoriale d'avoir déclenché des
règlements
qui mugellent un petit peu la parole des
uns et des autres je le regrette mais
ils n'ont été déclenchés qu'à partir de
l'article 7 et depuis le début il nous
semble que la gauche de cette hémicycle
veut ralentir le débat parce que moi
depuis que je suis dans cette maison
c'est la première fois que je vois des
amendements ident individuellement et
qui donc cherche à gagner du temps donc
nous dans notre ADN au sein du du RSE ce
que nous voulons avant tous ces débattre
et nous voulons aller jusqu'au bout donc
il faudrait clairement que chacun se
prononce sur la volonté d'aller au bout
parce que il est important il est de
notre responsabilité de débattre et de
faire en sorte que les Français
comprennent un petit peu mieux quelle
est la volonté des débats que nous avons
et en tout cas c'est pas l'image me
semble-t-il qu'on nous donne aujourd'hui
nous dans notre volonté c'est d'aller
jusqu'au bout merci
Monsieur chanterelle
chanterelle
si madame la Présidente je voulais en
fait parler plus globalement de
l'article 8 en par parce que vous nous
en avez privé au tout début avec vos
artifices et votre volonté de nous
bâillonner au niveau des de nos prises
de parole au début monsieur chanterelle
vous vous parlez de de des amendements
voilà et je vous remercie de laisser le
calme qui règne là dans l'hémicycle je
vous rassure c'est en lieu
donc en tout cas c'est pas la présidence
qui parle c'est la présidence de la
droite on dirait mais bon
on voit en tout cas
vous pouvez demander une suspension de
séance
je reprends la parole monsieur
chanterelle
monsieur chanterelle s'il vous plaît
je reprends la parole jamais vous
pourrez dire ça jamais tant mieux
pour tout le monde merci alors
maintenant je vous demande de faire
votre intervention et d'essayer de
garder le calme
alors
votre intimidation ne marchera pas merci
je sais que vous essayez je sais que
vous essayez de nous bâillonner de nous
intimider de plus plusieurs depuis hier
mais vous vous ne priverez pas les
français du débat
que ça soit à travers les coups de force
que vous faites depuis hier nous
continuerons nous continuerons à les
défendre même si ça vous plaît pas c'est
ça la démocratie il faut l'accepter donc
donc je par contre j'ai par contre j'ai
été coupé d'une minute mais bon
ce qu'il faut retenir justement de cet
article de du recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 64 ans
je vais demander une suspension de
séance madame la Présidente
c'est c'est que le recul de là ce sont
les plus fragiles justement ce dont
parle l'amendement de Monsieur Savary et
les plus fragilisés qui seront punis par
cette réforme et au premier chef
celle et ceux qui bénéficient d'une
retraite anticipée comme il reste pas
beaucoup de temps je vais prendre le
temps par contre de les citer parce que
ce sont les personnes qui sont victimes
justement de votre de votre réforme ce
sont les titulaires d'une pension
d'invalidité les travailleurs déclarés
inaptent au travail les allocataires de
la hache et de la location de cessation
anticipées d'activité les travailleurs
ayant eu une carrière longue les
travailleurs handicapés les travailleurs
qui ont une incapacité permanente à la
suite d'un accident du travail ou une
maladie professionnelle les
fonctionnaires handicapés les
fonctionnaires ayant eu
là c'est bon la parole est à Monsieur
karucci pour un rappel au règlement
madame la Présidente j'avais dit ce
matin que j'espérais je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi tout de suite
je me permets de dire à Monsieur
chanterelle et à l'ensemble de nos
collègues que si le climat restait
celui-là il faudrait appliquer la
totalité du règlement et dans la
totalité du règlement monsieur
chanterelle il y a un article 95 qui dit
très clairement que toute provocation
toute atteinte à la présidence de séance
entraîne la censure voir l'exclusion du
Sénat
pour un rappel au règlement
oui rappelle le règlement madame la
Présidente je sais que vous avez la
faculté de savoir ce qu'il y a dans les
amendements avant même de les lire c'est
ce qui est arrivé hier avec la
présidente de roche déclarant une erreur
d'habilité sans même avoir lu nos
amendements et là vous avez eu vous la
faculté madame la Présidente de savoir
ce que notre collègue chanterelle allait
dire avant même de l'écouter parce qu'il
a juste dit qu'on voulait nous
bâillonner il a le droit de le dire et
la suite la suite
laissez parler monsieur Durin monsieur
durable vous allez jusqu'au bout mais je
vous inviterai à relire le compte rendu
ensuite on regardera la vidéo ensemble
donc
la suite de la défense de l'amendement
la suite de la défense de la maman a
prouvé qu'on était bien sur le fond donc
je crois qu'il faut si vous voulez
effectivement éviter dans l'arrivée à
ces extrémités que nous promet monsieur
karucci on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver
là on n'est pas obligé d'en arriver là
donc je sais politiquement ça devient
compliqué sur ce texte parce qu'on voit
bien on a regardé les rectifications de
vote ça s'effrite et puis on voit bien
ce que dit la presse locale c'est pas
très populaire votre position on
comprend votre embarras on comprend
votre armoire donc laissez-nous
travailler vous connaissez notre
attachement à cette maison à l'ordre qui
règne à la qualité des débats qu'on sait
produire ensemble donc si vous
contribuez au calme et si tout se passe
bien vous pouvez compter sur nous
merci monsieur Durand mais il faut voir
les provocation de welvienne quand même
moi personnellement en tant que
Présidente je n'ai pas apprécié voilà
mes chers collègues je souhaite
sincèrement nos débats conservent la
sérénité qui fait la marque de fabrique
de notre assemblée et qui contribue à la
bonne image de notre travaux alors je
n'hésiterai pas afin de maintenir la
sérénité de nos débats à faire usage des
prérogatives que le règlement confère à
la présidence de séance et se rappelle
ayant été fait nous reprenons le cours
normal de la discussion
et donc les explications de vote et
c'est monsieur fierler qui a la parole
merci madame la Présidente moi je
voterai l'amendement de notre apporteur
Savary et je ne le voterai pas parce que
j'ai l'article 7 honteux ou pour me
racheter ou pour me rattraper d'une
mauvaise action j'aurais commise au
contraire je le vote parce que il y a
une cohérence à demander certains
efforts et à corriger par ailleurs
certaines inégalités je moi je ne suis
pas économiste et je n'écoute pas les
économistes d'ailleurs parce que il y a
plutôt des raisons de s'en méfier moi je
me base sur ce que me disent les gens
que je rencontre qui travaillent aussi
dur que ceux que rencontre la partie
gauche de cette hémicycle qui travaille
durement et qui ont aussi un peu de bon
sens quand l'espérance de vie augmente
de 10 ans depuis 40 ans quand il y a
plus de départ en retraite que de gens
qui rentrent sur le marché du travail
quand la démographie baisse écoutez il y
a pas besoin d'avoir fait Polytechnique
pour se dire que les choses sont pas
équilibrées et qu'avec un peu de bon
sens et bien il faut que nous fassions
tous un effort supplémentaire et les
gens qui travaillent dur qui se lèvent
tôt le matin etc sont prêts aussi à le
faire quoi qu'on dise ils l'ont déjà
fait par exemple lorsqu'on a demandé de
travailler un jour de plus pour les
personnes âgées et la dépendance et je
crois que c'est aussi l'honneur de nos
concitoyens c'est la marque de la
solidarité nationale quand on veut une
retraite par répartition que malgré les
difficultés la dureté du travail que
l'on que l'on a et bien on puisse faire
cet effort supplémentaire pour
équilibrer un régime des retraites et
éviter à nos enfants de payer à la fois
nos retraites et des dettes que nous
leur laisserons
si madame poncemo je prends un rappel au
règlement voilà on vient de voir un
nouvel échange tendu entre la droite et
la gauche sénatoriale autour de cet
article 8 on va rejoindre Alexandre
Poussard Alex vous avez suivi ça au
premier loge vous êtes en tribune de
presse on peut le dire c'est des bases
se tiennent au dessus d'une Soufrière en
quelque sorte effectivement c'est de
plus en plus tendu cet après-midi dans
les débats entre les sénateurs et là on
a peut-être même franchi un cap puisque
les sénateurs discutaient de cet article
8 de la promotion de la droite
sénatoriale et bien de mettre en place
une surcote des pensions de retraite
pour les maires de famille un sénateur
socialiste Yann chanterel a pris la
parole pour défendre un amendement alors
la règle c'est que le sénateur doit
parler de l'amendement du fond et pas
d'un sujet annexe et la présidente de
séance qui est une sénatrice LR Pascal
gruni a estimé qu'il ne parlait pas du
fond de la discussion et le sénateur
soci lui a répondu en disant qu'elle
n'était pas la présidente de séance
c'est-à-dire de toute l'institution
sénatoriale mais simplement la
présidence des républicains et ça c'est
vraiment une attaque qui a touché et
bien les sénateurs les républicains il y
a une bronca dans l'hémicycle à la
droite de l'émission car c'est vraiment
et bien une règle importante que la
présidence de séances en l'occurrence
une vice-présidente du Sénat soit neutre
représente toute l'institution et le
fait que la gauche estime qu'elle était
simplement la présidente des
républicains et bien ça a mis un peu le
feu aux poudres et à ce moment là un
autre vice-président du Sénat le
sénateur les républicains Roger caoutchi
a pris la parole en invoquant la
possibilité d'un article du règlement du
Sénat qui évoque et bien tout simplement
l'exclusion d'un sénateur qui
attaquerait personnellement la
présidente d'une séance au Sénat donc
voilà la droite sénatoriale qui a menacé
d'exclusion le sénateur socialiste Yann
chanterelle donc les débats se sont
vraiment un peu en venimés on va le dire
cet après-midi avant de reprendre une
discussion plus calme qu'on entend à
l'instant sur cet article 8 voilà des
menaces d'utilisation d'un article du
règlement un articlement qui n'a jamais
été utilisé de l'histoire contemporaine
récente du Sénat retour dans les débats
dans l'hémicycle
au sein de surcote
ben oui et donc là c'est certes mieux
que ce que nous propose le prochain le
projet de loi mais c'est bien moins que
ce que les femmes ont aujourd'hui et en
plus et en plus elles ont pas le choix
j'allais le dire Raymonde voilà elle non
pas le choix c'est-à-dire que
volontairement elle venge qu'à 64 ans
elles ont 10% là on les oblige à aller
jusqu'à 64 ans il y a 62 elles ont la
totalité de leur trimestre et on va
gentiment leur donner 5%. alors chers
collègues rapporteur je sais que c'est
sincère mais moi ça me plaît pas je sais
que beaucoup y compris voilà dans les
dans les rangs qui sont les miens trouve
que c'est plutôt pas mal moi à titre à
titre personnel à titre personnel
j'avoue que ça me c'est un amendement
qui ne qui ne me dérange pas bien
évidemment parce que
il est construit et tout ce qu'on veut
mais c'est un je ne le partage pas parce
que finalement c'est moins
que ce que elles ont aujourd'hui
merci Madame Vogel
merci madame la Présidente donc en effet
je crois que c'est important de le dire
et de le dire clairement l'amendement
sur lequel nous sommes amenés à voter va
consister à faire perdre des droits aux
femmes qui ont des enfants mais un peu
moins que ce qui avait prévu le
gouvernement aujourd'hui les femmes qui
atteignent le taux plein à 62 ans avec
leur trimestre de majoration peuvent
choisir de s'arrêter de prendre leur
retraite à 62 ans ou bien de continuer à
travailler et dans ce cas là si elles
vont jusqu'à 64 ans elle bénéficie d'une
charcute de 10%
donc ce qui nous est proposé ici né en
aucun cas un progrès par rapport à
l'existant c'est un moindre recul pour
les seules personnes qui ont fait le
choix d'avoir des enfants ça n'aura
aucun effet sur les inégalités
structurelles entre les femmes et les
hommes dans la société que nous avons
proposé à de nombreuses reprises de
corrigées par tout un tas de mesure que
vous avez systématiquement refusé je
voudrais juste finir en disant que pour
moi la famille n'est pas une valeur la
famille c'est une institution et comme
tous les institutions mais c'est pas un
gros mot institution excusez moi je sais
pas ce que c'est le problème que vous
avez avec le mot institution c'est une
institution comme toutes les
institutions ce sont des constructions
sociales et comme toutes les
constructions sociales elles ont
vocation à évoluer et nous avons le
projet de faire évoluer la famille pour
qu'elle soit moins concentrée sur l'idée
que la fille que la famille est une
affaire de femmes que les femmes sont là
pour faire des enfants et pour s'en
occuper
si Monsieur Chaumier
madame la Présidente je vais de
expliquer qu'elle va être mon vote
puisque c'est l'objet de cette
intervention de cet article auparavant
je voulais dire que les débats sont
cette hémicycle même s'ils sont entendus
ne sont pas inutiles et j'en veux pour
preuve que depuis que le vote a eu lieu
sur le report à 64 ans il y a une petite
dizaine de collègues qui ont abandonné
le vote pour et l'ont transformé en
compte ou abstention ce qui veut dire
que les arguments les explications
finissent par voilà un flux sur notre
position à chacun je voudrais dire à mon
collègue Bernard fialer d'ailleurs que
ce qui compte ça n'est pas l'espérance
de vie c'est l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé et quel stagne et on ne sait pas
ce qu'elle sera à l'avenir d'ailleurs
l'espérance de vie globale va
probablement régresser dans les années à
venir en tout cas comme aux États-Unis
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé on
n'en sait pas trop et je conçois que
cette définition est d'ailleurs assez
complexe mais toujours est-il que quand
on se fixe à cet indicateur il n'y a pas
vraiment de motif d'arguments pour
reporter l'âge légal de la part de
départ à retraite et puis sur cette
amendement du rapporteur moi malgré les
conditions dans lequel il a été présenté
et ce qui est une manœuvre même si elle
est réglementaire
qui a été menée pour aboutir à son
examen en priorité
évidemment c'est la question du verre à
moitié vide à moitié plein ou faut-il
atténuer accepter de voter l'atténuation
d'une d'un cadre général qui est très
négatif et c'était une atténuation qui
est partielle donc évidemment notre
groupe il réfléchit on est traversé on
est traversé sur cette question on n'a
pas une on n'est pas arrivé nous dans
cette hémicycle en ces temps mis
d'accord avec le gouvernement surtout et
en ayant une position de principe
surtout et donc je dis pas que tout le
monde on a vu que les votes changent je
l'ai dit donc je reconnais l'évolution
de chacun et donc peut-être que nos
votes seront différents sur cette
question moi je vais plutôt accepter la
proposition du rapporteur avec toutes
les réserves que j'expliquais merci
Monsieur longuet
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le
groupe républicain soutient avec
conviction l'amendement 21-27 rectifiée
le soutien avec conviction parce que
c'est amendement à l'immense mérite
d'ouvrir enfin le débat sur une réalité
française c'est que le régime par
répartition ne peut durer que si nous
avons un équilibre des naissances au
regard de la durée de la vie en retraite
or vous évoquez avec nostalgie le CNR
qui en effet au printemps 1944 avant que
la France même soit libérée a fondé une
politique sociale
dont auquel auquel appartient évidemment
ce régime par répartition nous avions à
l'époque et les circonstances étaient
quand même tragiques pour notre pays une
natalité de 21 pour 1000
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 11 pour 1000
c'est-à-dire à peu près moitié moins
cette décrue a été particulièrement
forte au début du 21e siècle nous étions
encore à 14 pour 1000 en 2000 nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 11 pour 1000 il y a
une véritable interrogation
comme rapporteur de budget de
l'Éducation nationale je puis vous
rappeler qu'il y avait 820 000
naissances en France en 2012 il y a 10
ans il y en a cette année 720
000 environ c'est à dire une décrue de
100 000 naissances en moins par an alors
heureusement la vie s'allonge et que le
nombre de retraités ne peut qu'augmenter
et il faut s'en réjouir votre amendement
monsieur le rapporteur rappelle cette
évidence qu'il évacue la totalité du
problème la réponse est non mais si nous
ne mettons pas le pied dans la porte à
cet instant nous serons également en
effet fondé à reconnaître que nous avons
manqué un rendez-vous madame la
Présidente je sais que vous êtes très
attentif on voudrait simplement dire que
la famille pour nous est une valeur
parce que c'est le respect de la parole
donnée de la parole donnée à son
conjoint monsieur
la parole est à Monsieur Breuillet non
non chers collègues
non non
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente pour ma part
je voterai cet amendement du rapporteur
Savary mais je le dis très honnêtement
je le voudrais par défaut
par défaut parce que
l'article 7 qui porte à 64 ans la mesure
d'âge plus l'amendement ça varie à cet
article 8 qui crée une surcote à 5%, ça
crée par rapport à la situation actuelle
c'est de articles additionnés ça crée un
recul un recul qui est plus limité que
le recul créé par le simple vote de
l'article 7 que vous avez voté hier
nuitamment mais un recul quand on
aggrave avec deux ans de plus puis qu'on
atténue avec une surcote cela reste une
aggravation c'est une aggravation
atténuée mais c'est une aggravation ma
deuxième remarque c'est que je le redis
j'ai entendu hier ou avant-hier une
proposition sur les groupes du centre
pour ne pas imposer le recul de la
mesure d'âge et je le dis c'est pareil
la surcote devrait rester un choix
personnel vous chers qui êtes les
apôtres de la liberté très souvent
pourquoi ne pas laisser aux gens le
choix de la liberté parce qu'il y a des
personnes qui peuvent être cassées et
qui peuvent aspirer absolument à prendre
leur retraite même avec une décote vous
le savez très bien d'ailleurs c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui donc laissons le
choix ne retardons pas la possibilité
pour chacune en l'occurrence de prendre
la retraite au moment où elle le décide
et laissons ce choix et puis enfin il me
reste que 14 secondes je veux dire que
je ne comprends pas ce débat sur le fait
que le travail ou la famille sont des
valeurs et j'aimerais qu'on prenne le
temps d'un débat évidemment un loi un
texte de loi de finance rectificative ne
se prête pas contraint dans le temps ne
se prête sans doute pas ce débat mais
c'est un débat très important et très
intéressant et la famille a beaucoup
changé vous le savez parfaitement donc
je ne sais pas ce que représente cette
valeur en tous les cas ce que je fais
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de familles
comme référente merci merci Madame
meunier
merci madame la Présidente je pense
qu'on assiste là un beau moment de débat
parlementaire moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire avec la prise de parole sur
l'amendement et l'article 8 et donc
l'amendement présenté par notre
rapporteur Savary
par cet amendement les choses ne sont
pas réglées dans les inégalités entre
les femmes et les hommes les inégalités
de salaire les inégalités de pension les
accès à des métiers qui sont encore trop
réservés à des femmes dans des
catégories de domaine du médico-social
du soin des services à la personne bref
cet amendement ne règle pas c'est
amendement règles la question des femmes
qui ont trois enfants et qui vont
bénéficier d'une surcote moi j'ai pensé
au départ que c'était un peu meilleur
que s'il y avait rien enfin la situation
actuelle mais on vous entendant mes
chers collègues plutôt ici je sais pas
s'il faut voter c'est amendement en tout
cas le doute s'est installé en moi et je
pense que au final je m'abstiendrai
désolé monsieur ça va
si Monsieur mouillé
merci Madame présidente j'aurai une
intervention en trois points tout
d'abord première intervention pour
soutenir l'amendement de rapporteur et
la remercier d'avoir trouvé cette cette
plus-value notamment qui remet en valeur
notamment la natalité et donc les places
des femmes dans notre société on regarde
un effort collectif collectivement nous
nous mobilisons pour travailler plus
longtemps pour l'équilibre de nos
retraites et je crois que c'est un signe
important de pouvoir bien apporter cette
cette plus-value donc c'est pour moi la
première intervention deuxième
intervention on a beaucoup entendu des
dans le débat des questionnements sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
en matière de rémunération en matière
d'emploi c'est un vrai sujet c'est un
sujet que pour lequel de cela doit
s'emparer mais ce n'est pas du tout
l'objet du texte c'était pas du tout
l'objet du texte et donc aujourd'hui
nous devons nous concentrer sur les
enjeux concernant l'équilibre de nos
retraites et puis troisième point
concernant les personnes handicapées
j'ai entendu beaucoup d'interventions en
disant aujourd'hui la situation va être
beaucoup plus difficile
ils sont dans l'effort collectif mais si
vous regardez bien l'ensemble du texte
vous prenez le temps de lire le texte
aujourd'hui pour eux rien ne va changer
puisque de nouveau l'âge de 55 ans sera
un âge barrière pour pouvoir pas arrêter
en retraite anticipée simplement dans
les évolutions proposées par le
gouvernement ont simplifie des
procédures et donc on améliore leurs
conditions voilà donc je voulais le dire
parce que j'entends beaucoup de choses
autour de tout ça et si vous vous
souciez aujourd'hui de l'enjeu du
médico-social au cours de ces débats sur
les retraites moi j'ai un petit service
à vous demander collectivement demander
à ceux qui sont en train de couper
l'électricité en France des
établissements médico-sociaux d'arrêter
on aura un enjeu fondamental pour nous
merci Monsieur Retailleau sur le
président Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
c'est un moment du débat qui est
intéressant puisque je remercie le
rapporteur d'avoir porté cet amendement
dont nous avions fait auprès du
gouvernement je vous le rappelle chers
collègues une vraie ligne rouge
il est intéressant ce débat pour deux
raisons
il est intéressant d'abord parce que on
assiste à un rarement
d'une presque convergence entre nous ça
a été Rare il faut le souligner il est
aussi intéressant sur le plan politique
parce que vous voyez durant ces derniers
jours j'avais été accusé puisqu'à
l'origine aussi de cette amendement
j'avais été accusé de vouloir absolument
une politique nataliste et que la
politique Nathalie c'était l'abomination
des abominations et je vois qu'il y a
une grande partie de la gauche qui est
restée fidèle à son héritage l'héritage
du Front populaire qui a inventé
la location familiale universelle
enrichie ensuite avec le gaullisme le
CNR ils ont fondé les socles d'une
politique familiale nataliste pour ceux
qui aiment l'histoire bien sûr il y a
une petite partie de la gauche
rare ici dans notre hémicycle qui
considère que évidemment la famille ça
n'est pas une valeur et que il faut
déconstruire tout cela qu'il faut
tourner le dos à ses cadres collectifs à
un destin commun au profit d'une
émancipation individuelle radicale mais
je suis heureux que au Sénat il yesset
de gauche social qui persiste et je me
suis toujours
j'ai regretté dans ma prof à vie
politique des dérives idéologiques pour
pouvoir le dire ici au sujet de la
gauche c'est un homme en fondamental
parce que l'impensé de la réforme du
gouvernement c'est la démographie un
régime par répartition c'est un régime
justement de transition démographique et
intergénérationnel les femmes sont déjà
les grandes perdantes puisque vous
l'avez tous souligné les maires de
famille encore plus puisqu'on écrase les
trimestres de majoration avec les deux
années de recul c'est quelque chose de
fondamental on ne peut pas penser
l'avenir notre régime sans une politique
familiale qui soit une politique
familiale vraiment vigoureuse et
volontaire merci Monsieur le castor
sueur
si Madame la
je voulais remercier Monsieur
Retailleau pour contribution à
l'histoire du Front populaire
je voulais lui dire que cette
contribution est quelque peu orientés et
que
c'est tout à fait contraire à la réalité
que de considérer que les hommes et les
femmes les ministres hommes et femmes
femmes et hommes qui étaient dans le
gouvernement du Front populaire était
contre ou aurait été contre une
politique de la famille ils ont au
contraire
fait beaucoup
fait beaucoup ils ont fait beaucoup à
cet égard ainsi et je vais dire aussi
que
que nous nous instruisons chers
collègues dans le droit fil de cette
politique du Front populaire et quand
vous essayez quand vous essayez de nous
présenter comme étant en contradiction
avec le Front populaire franchement
c'est une imposture que nous ne pouvons
accepter
merci chers collègues passer la parole à
Monsieur le Président Laurent
c'est ce que vient de dire le président
Retailleau qui m'incite à faire à mon
tour une explication de vote parce qu'il
faut être d'accord sur le sens de ce que
nous allons voter les uns et les autres
vous parlez de ligne rouge sur le
taillot pour ce qui est de la réforme
des retraites c'est une ligne Maginot
parce que la régression sociale
va être massive avec les 64 ans et elle
va être massive pour tout le monde et
pour les maires de famille comme pour
les autres donc ça n'est en aucun cas
une ligne rouge qui empêche cette
régression sociale massive donc nous ne
sommes pas en train de créer une
conquête sociale puisque vous avez fait
référence au Front populaire qui a été
une période de grande conquête sociale
nous sommes entrants dans le meilleur
des cas d'essayer de limiter un tout
petit peu les dégâts que va provoquer la
réforme que vous voulez absolument voter
et la deuxième chose que je veux dire
c'est qu'en matière de politique
familiale
le plus grave coût qui était porté à la
politique familiale française c'est le
jour où on a décidé que les entreprises
seraient totalement dégagées du
financement des allocations familiales
parce que vous avez décidé ce jour-là de
fiscaliser entièrement la politique
familiale et comme vous êtes les
premiers à expliquer tous les jours
qu'il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques c'est vous qui tarissez la
possibilité d'avoir une politique
familiale ambitieuse parce que vous avez
dégagé les entreprises
et la création de valeur ajoutée des
responsabilités en la matière et que
vous êtes les premiers à faire pression
sur le niveau des dépenses publiques et
des dépenses sociales donc ne nous
donnez pas des leçons en matière de
politique familiale merci
alors je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur le Rapporteur Savary et je vous
invite à rejoindre vos bancs pour le
scrutin public qui aura lieu ensuite
monsieur Kerrouche attendez monsieur le
rapporteur veut prendre la parole
on réagit tous
on réagit tous à aux prises de parole
qui ont été dites et justement pour
corriger
il veut plus parler
je suis sûr que ça vous aurait manqué
donc je rallume
pourtant pourtant il va falloir
je vous remercie madame la présidence
bien je suis pas étonné quand même que
notre collègue Bruno Retailleau ne
veulent pas ne veulent pas franchir la
ligne rouge j'en ai jamais douté
sur le sur le sur le fond on peut dire
que cet amendement fait que les choses
soient moins pires que pire mais
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
elle est avérée elle était verrée aussi
au moment de au moment de la retraite il
y a un écart de 28% sur les droits à la
retraite entre les hommes et les femmes
et quand on prend en compte uniquement
les droits directs et pas les droits
dérivés cet écart monte à 41%. donc il y
a une vraie difficulté et j'en viens à
toujours cette ce problème que notre
collègue fialère a évoqué tout à l'heure
vous avez dit mais cette réforme c'est
le bon sens parce que on vit plus
longtemps et donc d'une certaine façon
il n'y a pas besoin de sortir de
Polytechnique pour comprendre qu'il faut
faire plus rien n'est plus faux rien
n'est plus faux parce que encore une
fois je vous le répète vous raisonnez
sur des moyennes et en statistique ça
n'a pas de sens la moyenne est une
valeur générale ce qui compte c'est
l'écart à la moyenne et l'écart à la
moyenne il est complètement différent en
fonction du sexe et en fonction de la
catégorie sociale et en fonction du
revenu donc faire comme si la moyenne
concernait tout le monde c'est
complètement faux certains sont
directement touchés et impactés et faire
croire comme le gouvernement que cette
réforme est une réforme de bon sens
c'est justement un non-sens statistique
une erreur politique et une erreur
sociale
merci alors le scrutin public c'est sur
l'amendement avant je ferai sur
l'amendement
bah oui bien sûr
en fait j'ai donné la parole pour les
explications de vote surtout quoi mais
donc voilà il y a pas de souci merci de
votre générosité je voulais dire au
président Retailleau que je vais vous
prendre pendant deux minutes madame ma
présidente moi je suis disponible pour
un débat sur les questions
démographiques sur la question de la
natalité et sur les politiques
familiales mais je pense que d'abord il
faut passer par une analyse sérieuse de
ce qui aujourd'hui nous amène au chiffre
que vous avez donné d'un peu plus 700
000 naissances par an bon
non c'est le même chiffre que ce soit
l'un ou l'autre qu'il est donné c'est
voilà on observe qu'est-ce qui à mon
sens aujourd'hui est la principale cause
des hésitations des jeunes couples à
mettre des enfants au monde premièrement
les inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes aujourd'hui des jeunes femmes
conçoivent leur vie les jeunes femmes se
posent laissez-moi finir président en
retardieu je vous ai laissé moi finir
quand vous demandez à une jeune femme
quelle est la carrière qu'elle veut
faire des femmes très diplômées elles
vous répondent celle qui me permettra
d'avoir une vie compatible avec ma vie
familiale vous posez la question aux
garçons de la même promotion ils
répondent pas ça donc les jeunes gens
projettent leur avenir en fonction des
charges de famille et pour les jeunes
femmes l'âge du premier enfant qui est
de vrai sujet c'est l'âge de naissance
du premier enfant il ne peut arriver que
quand tout est sécurisé la carrière le
logement
le couple tout ça et donc et donc nous
avons la premier sujet deuxième le sujet
qui on peut comprendre que des jeunes
gens entre 25 et 35 ans s'interroge pour
savoir à quoi ressemblera le monde
demain dans lequel vont vivre leurs
enfants on peut pas on peut pas
la meilleure des politiques familiales
c'est aujourd'hui de rassurer des jeunes
sur le fait que nous prendrons toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour garantir à
leurs enfants de l'eau de l'air et un
climat bien sûr que si des co anxiété
est une donnée majeure comme l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes mais quand vous voulez on fait un
grand débat au Sénat moi je demande que
ça merci madame la Présidente donc je
vais donner la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur
très bien merci effectivement et si on
veut donner envie aux jeunes il faut
aussi quelque part que dans notre
discours nous n'ayons pas toujours un
discours minérabilisme ou apocalyptique
quand on parle du travail me semble-t-il
[Applaudissements]
moi je voudrais amener quelques
précisions parce que ce débat était
intéressant mais il y a eu également
quelques imprécisions
vous permettrait de les aborder je
risque de déporter quelques mais juste
une minute ou deux je vais être le plus
synthétique possible mais il me semble
que c'est tout à fait important de
rétablir effectivement il y a des
majorations de trimestres qui sont
perdus comme on peut dire effacer en
tout cas elle rentre pas en compte ni
dans la durée ni effectivement bien sûr
dans le compte dans le montant de la
pension mais en tout cas dans la durée
du fait de quoi nous sommes à 20% de
majoration qui soit actuellement perdu
quand on a là où je lâche on sera à 30%.
mais sauf que elles sont on est un taux
de 20% parce qu'il y a déjà le
commencement de l'application de la loi
Touraine et vous perdez des majorations
à la fois quand vous n'avez pas vos 43
triestres c'est sur la longueur et
également par le décalage de l'âge c'est
pour ça que cette réforme fait que
effectivement il y aura un décalage de
majoration et ça nous a pas échappé
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
convenu que une majoration méritait
qu'elle soit pris en compte et
cette mesure s'adresse
parfois aux hommes mais
principalement majoritairement aux
femmes
choix ou pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix vous dites on a plus le choix du
fait de du décalage de l'âge mais on n'a
pas plus le choix du fait de
l'allongement de la durée voilà parce
que si vous allez à l'âge et n'a pas de
la durée vous n'avez pas le taux plein
et si vous allez aller durer mais vous
avez pas là mais il faut continuer à
travailler donc les deux facteurs ces
deux piliers jouent c'est la subtilité
du dispositif qui à travers nos
raisonnements parfois nous échapper et
je le comprends tout à fait bien parce
que j'avoue que j'ai mis aussi longtemps
pour parfois le comprendre on dit que
effectivement par rapport à la surcotte
aujourd'hui une femme de 62 ans elle
part 62 ans être trimestre elle a
surcote sauf que pour arriver à avoir
ces 43 trimestres déjà 62 ans faut avoir
commencé à 19 ans
les 43 années excusez-moi merci les 43
années faut commencer à 19 ans quand
même donc on touche pas toutes les
femmes voyez il y a beaucoup de femmes
qui sont effectivement avec une durée
déjà plus importante un autre dispositif
vous dites avec la surcote de Maya pas
la surcotte avoir moins de sous bah non
non parce qu'elles vont travailler
effectivement là le fait born fait que
et ça a été bien compris et c'est pour
ça qu'il y a un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont mécontent l'effet
born force à travailler plus longtemps
moi je le reconnais bien volontiers
c'est le principe de la réforme de force
mais c'est la philosophie même de la
réforme sauf que effectivement ils
auraient peut-être une surcote mais
comme elle travaille plus longtemps
elles auront un salaire qui fait qui il
y aura effectivement une rémunération
plus importante et si c'est quelqu'un
dans la fonction publique comment on
calcule la retraite sur les six derniers
mois qu'elle aura son indice indiscert
qui va augmenter donc elle aura une
meilleure retraite donc elle rattrapera
éventuellement la surcote c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette mesure de 5%
est tout à fait significative dites-le
autour de vous si vous votez cela parce
que vous pourrez dire on a quand même
essayé d'améliorer votre pension même si
ça vient nous ne vous gênez pas pour le
dire
un autre point que je voulais simplement
signaler c'est que vous avez largement
dénoncé et injuste titre que le système
était inégalitaire par rapport notamment
au maire de famille mais dans d'autres
dispositifs et on a assisté je ne sais
plus quelle
diatribe là-dessus sur les différences
de traitement pour l'usure
professionnelle l'incapacité permanente
qui faisait que etc un certain nombre de
dispositifs inégalitaires et nous
l'avons constaté le principe de cette
réforme c'est que ce soit le moins
inégalitaire possible dans ces
dispositifs en conséquence c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous invite dans
le cadre de cette réflexion
à suivre ce qui sera proposé dans
l'amendement de Monsieur Retailleau en
ce qui concerne les régimes spéciaux
parce que nous avons le même
raisonnement faut trouver une durée de
retraite qui soit fonction si elle est
plus longue que les autres de l'usure
professionnelle et il s'agit que tout le
monde soit traité à la même enseigne
c'est pour ça qu'il est permis sans
animosité de faire en sorte que l'on
puisse avoir cette égalité sans attendre
70 ans mais en essayant d'avoir un délai
un petit peu plus contraint voilà la
réflexion qu'à l'animé la Commission en
tout cas merci de soutenir cet
abonnement c'est tout à fait décisif
merci à Bruno Retailleau de l'avoir
proposé merci alors je vais mettre voir
non j'ai
rénal après on passe au vote
je vais très court je vais être très
court mais toujours pour reprendre un
peu notre rapporteur quelquefois comment
dire s'envole un petit peu en disant si
vous le votez n'oubliez pas de rappeler
qu'il vient de nous
qu'ils viennent de nous je parle à sa
place c'est ce qu'il vient de dire et il
y a juste un petit problème que je
rappelle encore une fois c'est que
toutes les améliorations éventuelles
toutes les petites améliorations qui
peuvent subvenir ne peuvent venir que de
vous puisque il s'agit d'un accord
préalable avec le gouvernement vous
autorisant à déposer l'amendement parce
que si le gouvernement avait dit non
vous étiez article 40 et il y aurait pas
dans l'amélioration donc bien sûr que
nous ne le dirons pas
merci monsieur le Président alors je
mets aux voix donc les sous amendements
donc le premier c'est le 4876 le dernier
sous amendement j'ai dit amendement sous
amendement excusez-moi sont
identiques
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ne sont pas adoptés je
vais passer au vote donc de l'amendement
2127 de la commission avec un avis
favorable du Gouvernement donc qui se
fait sur la forme du scrutin public il
va être procédé donc au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà on est en train de vivre ce
scrutin public à l'antenne de Public
Sénat inscritin sur un amendement venu
de la droite et du centre un scrutin
autour d'un amendement très important la
surcote pour les femmes qui ont eu au
moins un enfant et qui ont toutes leurs
annunités et qui et bien lorsqu'il est
lorsqu'elle travaille entre 63 et 64 ans
vont bénéficier d'une surcote de 1,25%
par trimestre supplémentaire pour donc
et bien le fait d'avoir eu un enfant une
forme de compensation peut-être un des
effets négatifs de la réforme des
retraites en tout cas c'est ce que
disent la droite et le centre lorsqu'ils
ont proposé cette modification on va en
reparler avec notre journaliste
Alexandre Poussard juste après le
résultat de ce scrutin Alexandre qui va
pouvoir nous dire exactement ce qui se
joue avec ce débat autour de cette
amendement de la commission un moment
défendu par René Paul Savary qui donc
tient la position de la droite et du
centre au Sénat sur cette comme on va
suivre la suite et la fin de ce scrutin
public scrutin électronique et non pas
un scrutin à main levée un scrutin
électronique qui va permettre de
connaître la position de tous les
sénateurs sur cet amendement sont-ils
pour sont-ils contre on va voir le
descriptif précis dans l'hémicycle du
vote sur cette amendement un amendement
qui aura pris de longues heures d'examen
puisque on a vu un débat depuis
plusieurs heures autour de la réforme
pour les femmes autour également du fait
qu'il y avait des écarts de salaire
entre les hommes et les femmes Laurence
Rossignol qui a rappelé ce chiffre de
35% des cas en moyenne et donc on a
entendu la gauche qui a expliqué que
d'allonger l'âge de départ pénalise
particulièrement les femmes qui ont le
plus des carrières hachées ou des petits
salaires au cours de leur vie
professionnelle mais donc cet amendement
suffira t-il à rattraper ses effets sur
les carrières des femmes c'est en tout
cas ce que dit la droite alors que plus
personne ne demande à voter et qu'on va
pouvoir avoir le résultat du scrutin on
écoute le résultat on en reparle juste
après avec Alexandre
leurs résultats du scrutin nombre de
votants 344 exprimés 280 pour 280 contre
0 le Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
en conséquence tous les amendements de
suppression tombent
et j'ai aussi deux amendements qui
tombent le 4329 de même la présidente
assassin
et le 2863 de Madame Lubin
et donc nous avons 11 amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
c'est même lui voilà le Sénat qui vient
d'adopter cet amendement Savary sur la
surcote pour les femmes ayant eu au
moins un enfant 280 voix pour et
l'abstention donc d'une partie de la
gauche on va rejoindre alexandre Poussin
Alexandre vous êtes en tribune de presse
dites-nous tout sur les débats des
débats intéressants sur les carrières
des femmes on peut le dire et qu'est-ce
que vous avez vous retenus de ces
échanges bien Quentin on peut dire que
le débat s'est élevé ces dernières
minutes dans l'hémicycle du Sénat autour
de cet amendement sur la proposition de
la droite sanitaire de mettre en place
une surcote des pensions de retraite des
maires de famille sur les trimestres
cotisés à partir de 63 ans on va d'abord
écouter l'auteur de l'amendement le
rapporteur de la républicain René Paul
Sabri qui explique pourquoi c'est la
meilleure solution pour nuancer un petit
peu les pénalités des femmes dans cette
réforme des retraites c'est même un
membre du gouvernement qui avait admis
que les femmes étaient un petit peu plus
pénalisées dans cette réforme des
retraites par rapport aux hommes écouter
qui explique que c'est la meilleure
solution pour compenser un petit peu ses
pénalités on peut pas avoir comme
argument de donner
par rapport aux hommes parce que il n'y
a pas de différence
dans l'espérance de vie c'est la même et
en conséquence nous rendons dans une un
droit qui sur le plan européen est un
droit discriminatif des hommes par
rapport aux femmes donc nous n'avons pas
retenu ce type de dispositif voilà ce
qui nous a animé et à faire cette
proposition d'une surcote anticipée
voilà et cette surcote qui permet de
résoudre l'un des problèmes de cette
réforme des retraites c'est que les
trimestres gagnaient notamment par les
maires de famille grâce à leur
parentalité et bien certains trimesto
gagnés étaient annulés par ce relèvement
de l'âge de départ à 64 ans alors du
côté de la gauche et bien justement les
stateurs de gauche étaient divisés sur
cette surcote proposée par la droite
sénatoriale certains estimaient que et
bien c'était plutôt une bonne
proposition d'autres ne comprenaient pas
pourquoi et bien c'était uniquement les
maires de famille qui étaient concernées
par cet amendement et pourquoi il n'y
avait pas justement un amendement pour
toucher les inégalités dont les femmes
étaient victimes par rapport aux hommes
et justement c'est cette question des
inégalités salariales entre les femmes
et les hommes qui a été rappelés dans le
débat par Laurence Rossignol la
sénatrice socialiste les femmes qui
n'ont pas d'enfant sont dans la même
situation l'écart résiduel de
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes et de 9% indépendamment des
carrières celui qui reste apost égal
travailler égal diplôme égal donc en
excluant toutes les femmes qui ne sont
pas mère de famille de cet amendement
vous ne répondez pas à l'écart de
rémunération spécifique entre les femmes
et les hommes qui impactent également à
la carrière des femmes qui ne sont pas
mère de famille
et puis ce débat était aussi très
intéressant car il est venu sur la
question de la natalité puisque la
droite sénatoriale avec cet amendement
veut défendre une politique nataliste
pour la France pour faire face aux
déclin des naissances dans notre pays et
donc le président du groupe les
républicains Bruno Retailleau a défendu
à cet amendement avec vraiment une
vision nataliste pour résoudre le
problème démographique qui est un
problème majeur selon lui pour notre
régime des retraites et en face la
gauche à défendu une vision sur Noël qui
est un petit peu réactionnaire et qui
réduit la femme justement à sa fonction
reproductrice à la charge démographique
qui pèse sur elle donc voilà on a eu un
débat très intéressant sur la natalité
Quentin merci merci Alexandre Poussard
pour toutes ces explications depuis la
tribune de presse et donc je vous le
rappelle le Sénat qui adopte cette
surcote pour les femmes qui ont eu au
moins un enfant lorsqu'elles atteignent
l'âge de 63 ans elle cotise en plus
jusqu'à 64 ans pour cette surcote 280
voix pour zéro contre retour dans les
débats en direct
enfin c'est actuellement par décret nous
vous proposons de l'inscrire dans la loi
c'est notre rôle par ailleurs pour
conclure présenter ces mesures de statu
quo de faible avancées comme de
véritables progrès sociaux est une
hypocrisie alors que l'économie générale
c'est à dire la tendance de fond conduit
à une aggravation
y compris pour les personnes invalides
ou en situation de mon âge n'a pas été
modifié je vous remercie
le 417 monsieur Ferny
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues nous avons
souvent alerté le gouvernement et quand
je dis nous je parle de notre chambre
haute sur les dérives de ce gouvernement
dans son rapport au corps législatif
procédure accélérée devenue la norme non
ratification des ordonnances renvoie
constant au décret sous couvert
d'efficacité toutes ces décisions
éloignent la représentation nationale de
dispositions importantes les retires de
la discussion nous avons bien vu que
dans la construction de ce texte sur
l'avenir des retraites le gouvernement
ne s'était guère embarrassé d'écouter
les syndicats les partis politiques ou
même le Conseil d'État nous empêchant
même de pouvoir nous les écouter en
maintenant secrètent la note qui aurait
pu et dû éclairer nos échanges cet
article 8 est représentatif passez-moi
l'expression du bricolage du
gouvernement des annonces de progrès
social mais sans réel mesure de progrès
social notre amendement souhaite donc
rendre concrète les annonces non dites
par le gouvernement le présent article
prévoit plus particulièrement que
l'inaptitude où vous ouvre droit un
départ anticipé à un âge fixé par décret
en plus du bénéfice d'une retraite au
temps plein à cet âge il est ainsi prévu
que cet âge soit maintenu à 62 ans par
deux décret notre groupe ne souhaite pas
laisser de place à des renvois en décret
les discussions de ces derniers jours
ont montré comment comme l'absence de
décret a pu impacter le calcul des
retraites des enseignants par exemple il
nous paraît donc nécessaire de fixer dès
maintenant ces tâches anticipées de
manière aussi fixe que celui fixé dans
l'article 7 de la loi je vous remercie
de votre attention merci le 28 61 madame
Lubin
c'est un amendement qui vise à garantir
que l'âge de départ anticipé à la
retraite pour les allocataires de
l'allocation de cessation anticipées
d'activités les travailleurs ayant eu
une carrière longue les travailleurs
handicapés les travailleurs qui ont une
incapacité permanente à la suite d'un
accident du travail ou une maladie
professionnelle sera toujours de 62 ans
et non prendre cette disposition par
décret comme cela est proposé
actuellement
merci le 4581 monsieur Ferny
alors que le gouvernement limite
fortement le débat Parlement pardon
excusez-moi
madame la ministre madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je m'excuse chers
collègues
[Rires]
alors que le gouvernement limite
fortement le débat parlementaire est
réduit à peu de choses la concertation
avec les organisations syndicales nous
demandons par cette amendement de faire
dénégociations avec les partenaires
sociaux organisation syndicales et
patronales représentative au niveau
national et interprofessionnel un point
de passage obligé préalable au décret
merci le 2126 de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
un moment de coordination
merci avis du gouvernement
annoncé vraiment
manque un peu de sommeil
alors troisièmement identique le 2846
madame Lubin même Poumirol
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
moment encore une fois viens marquer
notre
refus de décalage de l'âge de la
retraite de deux ans et donc c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste vise à
ne pas décaler de 2 ans pour les
salariés qui sont affectés par des
risques professionnels puisqu'on sait
que dans leur cas la situation est
encore plus pénible et encore plus grave
donc nous demande donc à ce qu'ils n'ont
pas de recul
qu'est-ce que je dois
pardon
334 non
donnez moi une seconde
3374 madame ponce
oui merci madame la Présidente alors je
voudrais revenir sur le C2P vous nous
dites que c'est les au titre de du C2P
vous maintenez deux ans avant mais les
départs anticipés au titre du C2P vous
êtes bien d'accord désormais ne pourront
intervenir qu'à 62 ans nous proposons
par cet amendement de maintenir la
possibilité d'un départ anticipé à 60
ans pour
pour le C2P pour les
départs anticipés pour pénibilité ces
disposions surviennent alors que le
travail s'intensifie depuis 30 ans je
reviendrai pas sur les chiffres de la
DARES selon les chercheurs Thomas Barney
et Eric Defebvre la retraite présente
des effets bénéfiques pour la santé et
le bien-être de façon générale mais
vraiment plus pour les catégories
populaires largement exposées à
l'accroissement de la pénibilité au
travail selon eux le rôle protecteur de
la prise de retraite reste très
prononcée parmi les personnes dont le
travail a été éprouvant pour les
personnes confrontées à des contraintes
physiques la retraite améliore
principalement la santé générale mais ne
répare pas toujours les corps pour
autant tandis que pour les personnes
ayant subi des contraintes
psychosociales et bien effectivement ça
s'accompagne d'une diminution
sensible de l'anxiété de la dépression
pour la population masculine la plus
exposée à des contraintes physiques ils
observent que la retraite permet une
diminution des maladies chroniques de 13
%, une baisse de l'anxiété de la
dépression de 8 % et une baisse qui est
importante pour l'espérance de vie sans
un sans incapacité une baisse de 16% de
la limitation d'activité aussi le
meilleur remède à la pénibilité du C2P
c'est donc la retraite arrêtez d'user
les cordes des travailleurs de ce pays
monsieur le ministre et monsieur le
ministre
les manifestants voulant appeler ils ne
veulent plus perdre leur vie à la gagner
si le 433 c'est qu'il défend
madame gréaume
merci Madame ma Présidente c'est un
moment vise à ne pas décaler de deux ans
là je départ anticipé pour les salariés
affectés par des risques professionnels
merci le 1938 monsieur mouillé
merci Madame présidente comme je
l'évoquais lors d'une dernière
intervention nous avons regardé très
près la situation des travailleurs
handicapés aujourd'hui il y a cet homme
de mesures existent pour leur permettre
de partir en de façon anticipée à l'âge
de 55 ans car je devrais pas sur le les
risques professionnels sur le le taux de
fatigue aussi des travailleurs
handicapés mais cette situation n'est
permis ce que par décret et ce que je
propose vers cet amendement c'est que ce
soit mis dans la loi en dur et donc nous
puissions le fixer directement à 55 ans
qui est une véritable avancée et comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure je suis
également la volonté de simplification
du gouvernement pour la prise à
considération de cette période là voilà
l'objet de mon amendement merci quelle
est la vie de la Commission sur ces
amendements
monsieur rapporteur
c'est la vie de la Commission sur ses
amendements
prenez votre temps
de
j'étais perturbé par madame la
Présidente simplement ces amendements
effectivement portent quelque chose de
d'important là aussi c'est la prise en
compte d'âge d'agents anticipés
la Commission a gardé toujours je le
répète parce que dans ce que l'on va
vous proposer c'est également important
ce principe que les âges anticipés
voulaient dire retraite plus longue donc
si c'est une retraite qui est plus
longue par rapport à la prise en compte
de l'usure ça veut dire qu'il y a eu des
facteurs d'usure ou des facteurs de vie
très particulier on pense notamment à
l'invalidité la maladie qui font en
sorte que il est tout à fait légitime
que la société consacre un effort
supplémentaire tant sur le plan des des
mesures que sur le plan financier à ces
personnes qui ont un parcours un peu
compliqué du fait de certains facteurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a un
certain nombre d'âge dé par rapport à
cette âge légal proposé à 64 ans mais
comme vous voyez ça fait beaucoup d'âge
on arrive à 55 ans et c'est d'ailleurs
l'âge actuel pour les personnes en
situation de handicap qui ont une durée
d'exposition dont on reparlera
éventuellement tout à l'heure dans ce
handicap par rapport maintenant un
critère nouveau qui sont les critères de
trimestre cotisés ou réputés cotisés
mais pas l'ensemble des trimestres
validés ce qui est un dispositif
d'ouverture par rapport à cet âge et
effectivement on peut comprendre que
certains amendements veuillent inscrire
cet âge de 55 ans moyennant des critères
qui sont définis et fixent dans la loi
il y a l'âge également par exemple de 60
ans en ce qui concerne ou 62 ans on va
parler de ces deux P ou actuellement le
C2P c'est vous pouvez bénéficier de deux
ans avec le nombre de points qui vous a
donné des trimestres qui vous permettent
de partir de façon anticipée trop de
personnes prennent ce dispositif par
rapport à d'autres dispositifs et en
conséquence nous avons pensé il était
plus judicieux non pas de les laisser à
62 à 60 ans comme aujourd'hui puisque
deux ans moins l'âge légal ce qui les
laisserait dans le dispositif
d'exposition à certains risques mais
plutôt d'essayer de favoriser le temps
partiel rémunéré de façon complète en
déplafonnant les points vous le verrez
on vous le présentera le moment venu en
développe plafonnant les points
consacrés à ce temps partiel pour qu'on
les réserve pour la fin de carrière ce
serait un peu plus ça nous paraît
maintenant c'est discutable bien entendu
si vous vers la discussion ça nous
paraît judicieux de faire une transition
comme ça à travers le C2P en fin de
carrière pour finir de façon progressive
il y a également l'âge de 62 ans en ce
qui concerne l'invalidité l'inaptitude
c'est le droit actuel le gouvernement
propose de le mettre en agent anticipé
par rapport à 64 ceux qui veut dire que
on reste dans le droit actuel et de ce à
nous apparu effectivement par rapport à
ceux qui ont des invalidités des in
études au travail pour aider raison
médicale mais pas pour des raisons
professionnelles de le laisser à 62 ans
ceux qui par contre et c'est là qu'on a
une différence avec le gouvernement qui
sont dans l'incapacité permanente à au
moins 20% ou bien pour ceux qui sont
entre 10 et 20% selon un nombre
d'expositions 17 années d'exposer à
certains risques nous avons une
divergence avec Monsieur le Ministre
parce que nous pensons qu'il ne faut pas
décaler pour eux ce passage de 60 à 62
ans et nous souhaitons que maintenir à
60 ans cette âge pour retraite anticipée
pour invalidité compte tenu des critères
exposés et puis il y aura on le verra
tout à l'heure mais ça fera partie de
notre lourd encore quatre anges de
bornes proposées ou trois ou quatre mais
on verra le moment venu pour les
carrières longues et puis il y a toutes
les bornes qu'il y a concernant les
actifs les sédentaires c'est pour ça
qu'on essaye de faire en sorte que ces
personnes là puissent avoir un
relativement équivalent d'un métier à
l'autre ou d'un statut à l'autre qui
sont les bornes qui passent à 59 ans
notamment pour les actifs et 54 ans pour
les super actifs voilà un peu donc notre
raisonnement a été toujours le même et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je donne
un avis défavorable par rapport aux
propositions qui sont faites
puisqu'elles vont à l'encontre de ce que
vous propose votre commission des
affaires sociales merci en ce qui
concerne j'ai dû oublier un amendement
ou de d'explication
ça c'est vu qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
c'est vu je l'ai expliqué donc c'est le
maintien pour les amendements de 1846 à
433 le maintien du C2P donc comme je
voulais exposé et puis il y a une petite
différence où j'anticipe par rapport à
la réaction de madame poncemont je sais
ce qui est concerne
l'inscription à 55 ans on choisira
l'amendement de Philippe mouillé
je l'attendais je l'attendais non pas
par gentillesse ou pas mais c'est parce
que il faudrait rectifier le vôtre par
rapport à ce qu'elle s'est proposé c'est
pour ça que nous préférons l'amendement
1938 qui a inscrit bien le dispositif
parce qu'actuellement c'est un décret
donc on inscrit bien par contre il y a
effectivement une petite erreur et ce
qui fait que j'ai donné un avis
défavorable mais c'est le même esprit et
puis également ce qui concerne le 417
pour Monsieur benaro J'ai un petit
commentaire particulier parce que je
pense que l'auteur de cet amendement n'a
pas bien considéré ce qu'il proposait et
je ne peux pas croire qu'il s'agisse de
son intention parce qu'effectivement
entre l'objet et la volonté il y a une
large différence donc avis défavorable
merci
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente peut-être un
avis en trois points sur le fond mais
sur le rapporteur a dit
l'essentiel des arguments que le
Gouvernement partage simplement préciser
que le gouvernement donne un avis de
sagesse à la demande 21-26 de monsieur
le rapporteur un avis défavorable ou une
demande de retrait sur tous les autres
amendements puisque la plupart d'entre
eux comme la dimension le rapporteur
sont en réalité satisfait puisque
beaucoup des situations évoquées sont
des situations qui n'évoluent pas avec
le texte que nous vous présentons je
n'ai qu'une différence d'appréciation
avec monsieur le rapporteur qui concerne
l'amendement
1938 pardon je les ai mal de Monsieur
mouillé
l'idée là et nous la partageons puisque
nous souhaitons que le départ des
personnes en situation de handicap soit
fixées reste fixé à 55 ans l'article
351-3 que vous mentionnez dans votre
amendement précise que cet âge de départ
anticipé est fixé par décret et précise
que
cette et il est actuellement fixé donc à
55 ans
le Gouvernement n'envisage absolument
pas de modifier le décret puisque nous
voulons laisser 55 ans ce que nous ce
que je crains ce que nous craignons
c'est que la rédaction que vous proposez
disons au maximum 9 ans empêche
finalement qui que ce soit d'aller plus
loin par décret ça peut être un choix
mais en l'état de la rédaction du décret
et de la possibilité
ultérieure de la bouger nous
considérions c'était satisfait c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'était plutôt une
demande de retrait qu'un avis qu'un avis
favorable
merci sur ces amendements étaient des
explications de vote
madame nous revenons ici en salle des
conférences la salle qui joue que seul
l'hémicycle où se tiennent tous ces
débats sur la réforme des retraites car
j'accueille ici Bernard Chaumier bonjour
vous êtes sénateur à parenté PS de Paris
un mot sur et bien ce qui s'est passé
dans l'hémicycle un peu plus tôt cet
amendement venu de du rapporteur René
Paul Savary sur la surcotte pour les
femmes ayant eu au moins un enfant et
qui vient compenser selon la droite en
tout cas une partie de la réforme des
retraites et de ses effets délétères
pour les femmes une partie de
l'hémicycle la beauté vous qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait vous savez quand vous
avez une réforme comme ça qui fait des
femmes les grandes perdantes le
président Bruno retaillod du groupe les
républicains la redit dans l'hémicycle
et tout le monde le sait les femmes sont
les grandes perdantes et que derrière
vous aviez vous avez un amendement qui
vient compenser en partie mais en partie
seulement le rapporteur le reconnaît
offerte pour les femmes un élu il a le
choix entre deux choses de dire de toute
façon cette réforme est mauvaise et je
vote NON à tout ou de dire ce qui au
moins atténue les dégâts pour les femmes
je vote pour donc moi à titre personnel
j'ai voté pour mais ça ne se nait en
aucun cas un blanc ça ou un accord sur
cette réforme c'est seulement de dire
puisque si elle risque de passer ce qui
n'est pas certain et bien qu'au moins on
limite un minimum les dégâts pour une
partie des femmes puisque vous l'avez
dit il concerne que les mères cette
amende cet amendement ce qui est quand
même bizarre de mêler la politique
nataliste à une réforme des retraites
oui on a entendu des sénatrice de gauche
un rappelé les écarts de salaire
notamment la présidente Florence
Rossignol 35% des cas de salaire en
moyenne entre les hommes et les femmes
et on a entendu aussi Laurence Cohen qui
est voilà très active à la mission aussi
pour l'égalité de droit des femmes ici
au Sénat dire que il y avait les
carrières chez les petits salaires qui
touchaient les femmes c'est au final
quelque chose quelque chose qui compense
mais uniquement une partie de la
population qui est bien subi ces écarts
de salaire oui puisque l'amendement ne
concerne que les mères donc par
définition ce n'est pas le fait d'être
femme qui qui va compenser c'est c'est
la maternité et donc c'est une drôle
quand même de conception de la loi on
nous a reproché de ne pas prêter assez
attention à l'égalité devant la loi je
constate que là l'ensemble des femmes va
être pénalisée et durement et une partie
seulement en gros on demande aux femmes
de faire des enfants donc ça s'appelle
une politique nataliste pourquoi pas
mais ça se discute dans une loi sur la
famille et sur la politique nataliste ça
n'avait un peu rien à faire là je trouve
que vous voyez il y a une volonté comme
il y a une conscience de la majorité
sanatoriale que ce projet de loi emporte
des tas de conséquences négatives pour
beaucoup de personnes dans la population
les femmes les plus précaires les
métiers pénibles ils essayent de poser
des un peu partout
on a entendu votre argumentaire dans les
mystiques un peu plus tôt dans la
journée vous avez fait remarquer que
certains sénateurs de la majorité de la
droite et du centre avaient demandé à
changer leur vote au lendemain de cette
adoption de l'article 7 celui sur la
mesure d'âge alors certes ne concerne
que quelques sénateurs et cela ne
changera pas l'issue du vote qui a eu
lieu hier et qui a entériné l'adoption
cet article mais vous l'avez noté avec
un assistance cela parce que c'est quand
même un fait majeur déjà le report à 64
ans a été voté sans les voies d'une
quarantaine de collègues de la droite
des républicains ou du centre qui ont
préféré s'abstenir ou voter contre ce
qui déjà est déjà hier il y avait eu à
la suite de ce vote on apprend
successivement que 3 puis 5 c'est-à-dire
quand même 8 collègues changent leur
vote et ne veulent plus voter pour je
crois que ça sera depuis quelque chose
d'abord que c'est que les débats qu'on
mène dans cycle même s'il déplaise aux
républicains et ben les arguments que
l'on porte finissent par être entendu
par un certain nombre de collègues et la
deuxième point qui est très que je salue
c'est que nous avons des collègues qui
écoutent aussi ce que dit le peuple qui
sont retournés dans leur département qui
ont discuté avec des citoyens dans leur
département qui leur ont dit que ça
n'était pas possible de voter ce
tréteforme il change leur vote il faut
noter que maintenant il y a moins de 200
voix pour au Sénat c'est tout à fait
inédit et ça rend très aléatoire la
poursuite de la réforme qu'est-ce que ça
dit il nous reste un peu moins d'une
minute pour finir à quelques questions
mais qu'est-ce que ça dit de ce qui
pourrait se passer si on allait jusqu'à
l'article 20 et l'ensemble du texte
est-ce que vous croyez qu'il y aurait
une majorité à droite et au centre pour
vanter voter l'ensemble de du texte j'en
sais rien chacun prendra ses
responsabilités on verra bien mais je
veux souligner que à l'issue du vote au
Sénat qui déjà montre une majorité très
affaiblie autour de cette réforme de
retraite il faudra que l'Assemblée
nationale
la valide et il est probable que le
gouvernement doit viser du 49-3 merci
merci Bernard jaumier pour cette
réaction au micro public c'est là nous
on retourne dans l'hémicycle pour suivre
ces débats en direct
favorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui abstiens ils ne sont
pas adoptés et enfin le 19-38 qui a reçu
un avis favorable de la commission une
demande de retrait du gouvernement qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
je sais pas si c'est 18 amendements
maintenant en discussion commune
commençant avec le 43 34 kit défend
madame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente le
Gouvernement présente la création d'un
dispositif carrière super longue et le
statu quo concernant le dispositif
carrière longue existant comme des
mesures de justice sociale or les
dispositifs carrières longues ne seront
pas renforcés en réalité l'âge de départ
pour les bénéficiaires de carrière
longue qui ont commencé à travailler à
18 ou 19 ans sera allongée de deux ans
soit un départ à 62 ans en 2030 et ce
ayant commencé avant 18 ans pourront
toujours partir à 60 ans mais il
connaîtront un durcissement de leur
situation puisqu'ils devront s'acquitter
de la durée de cotisation majorée d'un
an c'est un véritable en fait coup de
communication le gouvernement maintient
à 58 ans l'âge de départ pour celles et
ceux ayant commencé à travailler avant
16 ans soit moins mes chers collègues de
1% des générations qui sont touchées par
la réforme en effet pour la génération
1973 le dispositif de carrière super
longue ne concerne
pas plus que 300 personnes par an
environ et là je moyais d'accès un
premier emploi stable et passer de 20
ans en 2060 en 1975 pardon à 27 ans
aujourd'hui du coup notre amendement
vise à supprimer les trois bornes d'âge
de départ anticipé pour les carrières
longues et très longues merci Madame
ponce pour le 36 68
merci Madame ma présidente alors
vous renvoyez un décret la définition
des âges anticipés des départs anticipés
pour carrière longue et des conditions
de durée requises dans le texte proposé
la seule référence au dispositif
envisagé et dans le fait de remplacer je
cite les assurés qui ont commencé leur
activité avant un âge etc etc
par les assurés qui ont commencé leur
activité avant un des trois âges
sous-entendus 16 18 et 20 cette
modification n'apporte rien à l'état du
droit puisqu'il y avec la rédaction
actuelle il existe déjà quatre rages 16
17 18 et 20 ans pire la modification
envisagée vient figer elle vient figer
des possibilités du pouvoir
réglementaire en matière d'âge alors
qu'il s'agit au contraire d'un paramètre
sur lequel il faut trouver le plus de
souplesse possible au profit ici de la
durée d'assurance requise actuellement
le décret dispose que les assurés ayant
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans
doivent justifier d'une durée de
cotisation équivalente à celle requise
pour le taux plein les assurés ayant
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
doivent justifier de cette durée mais
majorée de 8 trimestres le gouvernement
dans ce dossier de presse prévoit
d'abaisser cette condition à quatre
trimestres
avant 16 ans de majorer cette durée de 4
trimestres pour ceux ayant commencé
avant 18 ans et ne prévoit pas de la
majorée comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour les assurer et ont commencé avant
20 ans c'est très compliqué hein nous
vous proposons donc de modifier les
dispositions envisagées c'est la
conséquence et de supprimer à chaque
fois la référence aux trois âges vous
voyez la complexité qu'on en parle et de
les remplacer par une disposition claire
précisant les conditions de durée
requises en précisant que la durée de
cotisation requise pour l'anticipation
au titre de la carrière longue est égal
à la durée d'assurance requise pour le
taux plein c'est bien plus simple vous
en conviendrez merci Madame madame Lubin
pour le 26 35
merci madame la Présidente moi je vais
pas relire le motif parce que l'objet
parce que c'est exactement le même que
celui de ma collègue Raymond de penser
mange donc je vais poser le problème
[Musique]
ce projet de loi amène à avoir des âges
extrêmement différents en matière de fin
des durées différentes en matière de
carrière longue alors il y aura il y a
une dispositif pour ceux qui auront
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans
certes c'est bien il existait déjà un
certain nombre de choses bon ça
concernera très peu de gens au final
mais ça aura le mérite d'exister
aujourd'hui les gens qui ont commencé
qui ont cotisé 5 trimestres avant 20 ans
et qui ont le nombre de trimestres
requis à l'âge requis peuvent prétendre
à une carrière longue des 60 ans bon
cela qui vont constituer et qui
constitue déjà et qui constitueront
encore plus dans les 10 années qui
viennent le gros de la cohorte des
carrières longues cela vont devoir
continuer à travailler jusqu'à 62 ans
alors certes c'est un peu le débat qu'on
avait tout à l'heure pour eux 62 ans ça
sera mieux que 64 mais c'est pire que 60
on est bien d'accord et pour la plupart
ce sont des gens
qui travaillent déjà on l'a dit depuis
longtemps puis ce sont ceux-là que l'on
retrouve dans tous les métiers dont on
n'arrête pas de parler voilà donc moi
j'amène tout le monde à réfléchir quand
même pour un certain nombre de ces
personnes là
deux ans de plus lorsque la loi sera
totalement vigueur ou quelques mois à
partir de maintenant ça n'est pas rien
donc effectivement nous ce que nous
préconisons c'est 43 ans de cotisations
et on s'en va
merci nous avons maintenant trois
amendements identiques le 45 monsieur
Cabanel merci madame la Présidente le
dispositif de retraite anticipée pour
carrière longue a été mis en place en
2023 pardon dans un esprit de justice
sociale pour accompagner les réformes
d'un logement de la durée d'assurance
requise les assurés qui ont commencé à
travailler particulièrement tôt et qui
remplissent certaines conditions de
durée d'assurance peuvent ainsi
bénéficier d'un départ en retraite
anticipé pour carrière longue afin
d'amortir l'impact du relèvement de
l'âge légal sur les assurés qui ont
travaillé le plus tôt l'article 8
modifie les conditions applicables aux
carrières longues l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour longue carrière serait
ainsi anticipée selon trois bornes d'âge
c'est amendement propose de créer une
quatrième borne d'âge de début
d'activité permettant un départ anticipé
pour les assurer ayant travaillé avant
21 ans cette nouvelle borne d'âge
permettra aux assurer et en réuni quatre
si un trimestre avant 21 ans et
justifiant de leur durée d'assurance
requise cotisée de partir à l'âge de 63
ans les âges de début d'activité et
l'âge de départ possible sont définies
par décret un décret précisera par
ailleurs que pour l'ensemble des niveaux
de dispositif carrière longue la
condition de durée cotisée sera fixée
conformément à la durée d'assurance
requise pour le droit commun ainsi
assurer pourra partir à la retraite à
taux plein si la cotisée au moins cette
durée dès lors qu'il aura atteint l'âge
anticipé de départ au titre des
carrières longues
c'est à vous merci Présidente c'est
amendement présenté par mon collègue
Xavier yakovelli et notre groupe est
exactement le même que celui qui a été
excellenté par notre collègue Cabanel
donc je n'en dirai pas plus très bien
nous avons maintenant le 3407
identique madame ponce
oui il est identique mais je tiens à
ressouler effectivement et ça va être
souvent le cas que nous c'est amendement
les sénateurs du groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire souhaite atténuer
la brutalité de la réforme portée par le
gouvernement effectivement l'article 8
précise que l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour longue carrière peut être
anticipée selon trois bornes d'âge vous
avez vu quand même qu'on proposait
d'autres formulations donc je continue
au cas où l'amendement précédent ne sera
pas retenu qui sont définis par décret
l'accès au dispositif est en effet
conditionné un début d'activité 16 18 20
ans le président amendement a pour objet
malheureusement vu cette complexité de
créer une possibilité de départ anticipé
pour les assurer ayant travaillé avant
21 ans en créant une quatrième borne
d'âge de début d'activité
c'est conformément aux annonces de la
première ministre du 5 février 2023
conformément à cet engagement un décret
précisera également que pour l'ensemble
des niveaux de dispositifs carrière
longue et c'est ça qui est important la
condition de durée cotisée sera fixée
conformément à la durée d'assurance
requise pour le droit commun aujourd'hui
quoi qu'on en pense c'est 43 à nuités au
terme de l'accélération du calendrier
Touraine dès lors qu'il atteint la
anticipé de départ routine des carrières
longues l'assuré devra pouvoir partir à
la retraite à taux plein six va cotisé
au moins cette durée requise merci merci
pour le suivant le 208 monsieur mandoli
il est défendu le 43 36
qui le défend
ces messieurs ça vole de vie
ça va être monsieur ça veut dire
merci madame la Présidente
aujourd'hui pour accéder à la retraite
anticipée pour handicap à 55 ans il faut
remplir deux conditions cumulatives à la
fois validé une certaine durée
d'assurance trimestre cotisée puis
trimestre assimiler doit un certain
nombre de trimestres cotisés et là la
réforme propose de ne plus retenir que
la cotisation de la condition de durée
cotisée cela réduit certes la durée
totale d'assurance pour bénéficier du
dispositif mais à nos yeux cela ne rend
rien à programmer problématique la durée
de cotisation reste beaucoup trop longue
pire cela
risque de rendre encore plus compliqué
l'accès aux dispositif car les
trimestres assimilés mais non cotisés
notamment au titre du chômage d'un arrêt
de maladie d'un stage etc ne sont plus
plis en compte d'ailleurs ce retour en
arrière en totalement en contradiction
avec l'article qui prévoit de mieux
prendre en compte les périodes de stage
de formation professionnelle donc on
peut être favorable à la réduction de la
durée d'assurance totale exigée mais il
est inacceptable de supprimer la prise
en compte des trimestres validés il faut
maintenir donc cette possibilité de
prendre en compte les trimestres
validées assimilés et élargir les
périodes reconnues comme tel que ce soit
des pertes de chômage d'arrêt maladie
accident du travail période de stage de
formation professionnelle perte
d'apprentissage période de service
civique etc il faut également réduire la
durée exigée de cotisations situation
d'handicap d'au moins 20 trimestres car
une personne en situation de handicap
ayant passé plus de 5 années au chômage
ou en maladie ne pourra pas prétendre à
une retraite anticipée en remplissant
les autres conditions c'est vous dire
que cet amendement n'est pas
l'amendement seulement de notre groupe
c'est nous l'avons déposé avec l'esprit
de ce que nous a demandé de mettre ici
en débat qui a été réalisé par le
collectif handicap qui correspond et qui
rassemble 52 organisations plan national
sur cet enjeu de la question du handicap
donc il faudrait faire bénéficier les
personnes dont le handicap survient à
compter de 40 ans et qui ont un taux
d'incapacité supérieur à 50%, merci
monsieur le ministre le
l'article 8 prévoit la prise en compte
des trimestres à kiotiques de
l'assurance vieillesse par en foyer et
de l'assurance vieillesse des aidons
pour calculer le bénéfice de la retraite
anticipée pour carrière longue par
dérogation en principe qui fait que
celles les trimestres cotisées par la
surées sont prises en compte dans la
rédaction retenue à l'Assemblée
nationale seuls les trimestres prises en
compte sont seuls trimestre en compte
pardon sont ceux au cours desquels les
intérêts ont été affiliés au régime
général or les périodes de cours
desquelles les assurés étant aidons
étaient aidons et aux parents au foyer
peuvent être fait au titre de la CNRACL
ou au titre de la cpcmr et donc nous
proposons d'élargir aux autres régimes
la prise en compte des trimestres
d'assurance vieillesse par employés et
d'assurance vieillesse des aidants pour
la prise en compte des trimestres dans
le calcul de l'éligibilité au départ
anticipé pour carrière longue
monsieur le rapporteur l'amendement ou
madame
monsieur rapporteur un moment de la
commission merci c'est une la correction
d'une erreur est actionnaire
pensez 80
merci Madame ma présidente alors telle
que le prévoit le gouvernement la
détermination de trois as de surcroît
par décret pour permettre un départ
anticipé en salle des conférences avec
leur darkos bonjour Laure cause vous
êtes c'est net jour LR2 de la délégation
au droit des femmes on a vu un peu plus
tôt dans l'après-midi c'est sans doute
un amendement le plus important qui a
été adopté depuis plusieurs heures cet
amendement de la commission donc de la
droite et du centre sénatorial qui
souhaite et bien une surcote pour les
femmes ayant eu au moins un enfant
quelle est l'idée avec avec cet
amendement qui a été adopté à 280 voix
pour zéro contre ben écoutez c'est
c'était comme d'ailleurs l'a dit les
bancs enfin sur les bancs de la gauche
certains de mes collègues à moindre mal
par rapport à ce qu'on avait pu nous
annoncer on la gauche j'étais un chiffon
rouge au début de la présentation de ce
projet loi par le gouvernement comme
quoi une femme devrait
finalement travailler quasiment jusqu'à
67 ans
d'avoir cette surcote ça permet dans la
dernière année
de pouvoir avoir ce petit plus par
trimestre c'est bien sûr alors certains
vont dire encourager natalité
si vous voulez c'est aussi parce que les
carrracher alors bien évidemment qu'elle
peut être due aussi malheureusement à
des périodes de chômage ou de
difficultés psychologiques ou familiales
dans sa vie mais elles sont quand même
en grande majorité dû aux coupures dû au
grossesse et à des complications liées à
la vie familiale ça a beaucoup changé
maintenant que la nouvelle génération ou
les paires avec les congés parentaux en
prennent leur part mais on parle encore
d'une génération où c'était vraiment
très majoritairement les femmes qui du
coup à cause de grâce je préfère dire ça
alors vite famille ont eu ces carrés
hachés donc c'est une façon quand même
aussi de rendre hommage vous pensez que
cela améliore la réforme suffisamment
par rapport à tout ce que les femmes
peuvent perdre par ailleurs avec cette
réforme des retraites non bien
évidemment ça ne sera jamais assez moi
j'avais moi-même déposé un amendement
demandant à ce que on puisse en effet
pour les femmes partir plutôt à 62 ans
mais
on nous demande à tous de faire des
efforts et je pense et ça a été dit même
sur les bancs également de l'opposition
sénatoriale
ça n'est que la conséquence de
des disparités encore salariales qu'on
peut avoir effectivement pour les
salaires 35% des cas entre les hommes et
les femmes on avait un petit déjeuner
avec les habits de borne hier matin pour
quelques membres de la délégation en
droit des femmes et on en a beaucoup
parlé notamment l'indice Pénicaud du
renforcement en fait des sanctions par
rapport aux entreprises qui bien
évidemment
ne n'appliquerait pas cette égalité
salariale et donc moi c'est des sujets
sur lesquels je j'essaie de travailler
beaucoup au sein de la délégation alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a répondu
Elisabeth borne puisque vous l'avez vu
hier et que vous nous la prenez à ce
micro est-ce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle vous
a dit réfléchir de nouvelles trains de
mesures sur ces différents salariales ou
ces inégalités oui justement on a on a
parlé en effet du fait que aller
renforcée
mais on a aussi parlé des quelque chose
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
des
de tous les le
[Musique]
excusez-moi c'est la fatigue des nuits
les
secteurs de du numérique notamment et
scientifique mais surtout numérique pour
essayer de renforcer l'attractivité
vis-à-vis des femmes dans ces
secteurs-là donc voilà on a au-delà
également d'un renforcement mais ça je
veux pas dévoiler dans leur plan égalité
homme-femme d'une amélioration aussi de
certains certaines choses se concernant
les violences faites aux femmes qui
restent bien évidemment un sujet
très important pour nous délégation pour
notre sujet qui touche finalement en
retraite moi je dis surtout en effet
qu'on a besoin peut-être une grand texte
sur l'emploi où là on pourrait revenir
bien évidemment sur la disparité
homme-femme un fameux pardon et qu'on
puisse revaloriser bien évidemment le
travail des femmes j'ai une dernière
question cela concerne les coupures de
courant qui ont pu concerner certaines
circonscriptions où il y a des bureaux
de sénateurs leurs bureaux leurs bureaux
où ils accueillent leur concitoyens
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
coupures on a entendu Bruno Retailleau
les dénoncer dans l'hémicycle un peu
plus tôt dans la journée oui c'est
absolument scandaleux alors bien
évidemment c'est pas du tout
c'est pas son panneaux nos amis
parlementaires qui qui sont derrière
tout ça simplement je trouve ça
proprement scandaleux scandaleux nous
prendre en otage et pendant même son
temps de parole pendant que Bruno
Retailleau parlait lui-même il avait la
propre coupure dans son quartier dans le
quartier de son de sa permanence donc en
Vendée et puis surtout on a appris que
autour de la permanence de Gérard
Larcher dans les Yvelines à Rambouillet
du coup une clinique a été plongée dans
le noir le temps que bien évidemment en
effet on puisse y mettre j'imagine les
tous les les
générateurs et ça ça perturbé les
services tout ça est dramatique début
janvier un quartier de Massy dans mon
département d'Essonne avait été plongé
dans le noir entre 6h et 8h du matin je
pense que les grévistes pensaient que
c'était un quartier des affaires alors
que c'était un quartier d'habitation et
ça du gênait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de Sonia c'est donc que il y
avait des discussion de se débat c'est
que voilà on voit l'importance aussi de
ce qui se joue dans l'hémicycle depuis
10 jours vous le dites aussi oui je le
dis d'autant plus que et ça j'en suis
assez fier et je le partage avec
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle beaucoup
beaucoup de Français ne concitoyens nous
ont dit qu'ils attendaient aussi de nous
de redorer le blason en fait du
Parlement et de la politique en général
moi j'étais absolument atterrée des
spectacles du spectacle qui avait donné
l'Assemblée nationale et je me disais
qu'en effet il fallait pas s'étonner
après que les gens n'aillent plus voter
et du coup je pense que on était
d'autant plus attendus et peut-être par
curiosité au-delà même du du sujet des
retraites qui est bien sûr fondamentales
je pense que les gens étaient intéressés
de voir peut-être la différence de de
façon de de pouvoir échanger même si je
dois dire que depuis six ans je n'ai
jamais assisté à des débats aussi
musclés
on va le dire comme cela s'est tendu
effectivement notamment depuis 48 heures
autour de l'article 7 effectivement on a
pu vivre tout tout ça sur l'antenne de
public là merci Lord Archos merci d'être
venu à ce micro nous on retourne dans
l'hémicycle pour écouter René Paul
Savary merci proposons de partir avant à
la retraite pour
[Musique]
dire il y aura tel durée pour telle pour
ces personnes là parce que selon l'âge
selon les mois de naissance vous avez
une répercussion différente et vous
rentrez où vous rentrez pas dans le
dispositif et que les 43 ans puisque
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
c'est une durée de cotisation plancher
ce n'est pas une durée de cotisation
plafond les 64 ans âge légal c'est un
âge minimal de départ en retraite ce
n'est pas un plafond c'est la même
gymnastique d'esprit qu'il faut faire
pour comprendre le dispositif mais ce
serait au simple mille excuses là aussi
c'est pour ça que je suis vous l'avez
compris avec une position qui est pas
toujours en accord avec celle de
Monsieur le Ministre mais il partage les
principes de mes propositions je prends
5 minutes pour les exposer
oui mais c'est parce que c'est un
travail déjà de longue haleine là-dessus
de très longues haleine je me permets de
les exposer mais vous me ferez moi j'ai
pas réussi j'ai pas réussi à faire une
contre proposition c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai donné une commission à
donner un avis de sagesse j'ai pas
réussi à faire une contrepoolique
simplement vous prenez pour ces
carrières longues dans la loi c'est
marqué que ces quatre à cinq trimestres
avant votre année anniversaire la fin de
l'année celui qui a trois trimestres il
est pas dans le dispositif c'est la
borne suivant et 4 à Saint trimestre à
la fin c'est pas facile à expliquer
parce que pour les autres dispositifs
communs vous partez quand vous avez
telle durée quel que soit votre date de
naissance vous avez 43 ans de cotisation
et bien vous partez à la retraite c'est
pas avoir catalyse un trimestre avant le
début et puis ensuite
ce serait trop simple il y a le
dispositif de la durée quand vous
calculez la durée de ces dispositifs
car entre trois ans
qui sont affectés à une borne durée de
cotisation plus de c'est la réforme
naturelle sur la bosse de la borne de
ses ans c'est durées de cotisation plus
deux 43 + 2
= 45 ans quand vous appliquez cette
durée de cotisation et que vous comptez
les trimestres ce ne sont pas les mêmes
trimestres comptés que pour le régime
général d'un côté on se rend compte que
les trimestres cotisés c'est-à-dire
qu'il y avait véritablement les gens qui
ont travaillé concotisé ou réputés
cotisés parce qu'il y a une petite marge
de solidarité de l'autre côté on a un
système très solidaire qui permet de
prendre en compte certes les années
cotisées mais également quand vous avez
été malade des indemnités journalières
le chômage des réputés cositisées et des
assimilés et des majorations notamment
on en a parlé tout à l'heure qui fait
que dans les 43 ans il y a pas forcément
43 ans de travail il y a aussi 43 ans
qui sont compensés au titre de la
solidarité c'est un régime très
solidaire cette solidarité dans le
régime général ne s'applique pas au
régime des carrières longues ce qui fait
que quand on décline le dispositif vous
avez quelqu'un qui part à 20 ans puisque
c'est une nouvelle bonne vingt ans
voyez-vous quand il a ces quatre cent
trimestre avant la fin d'anniversaire de
sa 20e année quand il est dans un
dispositif où il a fait une grande école
par exemple
rémunérer et bien rentre dans le
dispositif et il va partir à 63 ans
c'est la proposition parce qu'il a
Polytechnique par exemple l'école des
impôts deuxième exemple donc il va
rentrer et le bien portant qu'à une part
guerrière sûrement difficile parce que
c'est sûrement difficile
partira 63 ans celui qui est dans les
mêmes conditions mais qui fait une autre
école qui est pas ou qui est rémuné ou
qui part dans sa carrière il est dans
les mêmes dispositions 4 à 5 ans avant
il arrive lui il a été malade il a
continué à travailler il a eu un entrain
de d'indemnité journalière il a repris
le boulot il a eu un amitié journalière
et ben celui-là comment compte pas les
trimestres de la même façon et ben il
part à 64 ans donc voyez-vous pour
partir avec un départ anticipé il faut
être bien portant avec un métier pas
trop difficile pour partir dans les
autres conditions celui qui a un métier
usant et qui peut être malade et ben il
bénéficie pas du dispositif il est clair
il est illisible parce que effectivement
c'est 4 à 5 ans etc et on peut toujours
mettre des bornes on peut toujours
mettre des amendements sur les durées de
cotisation le dispositif est-elle que
les dispositions se prennent par décret
donc moi j'ai tendance à donner
effectivement et la commission aussi un
avis de sagesse par rapport à cela parce
que vous avez la possibilité
effectivement de trouver le système le
moins inégaléaire possible et quand on
dit 43 ans comme c'était proposé à
mettre sur chacune des bornes on peut
toujours le voter moi j'ai aucun
inconvénient là-dessus sauf que vous
dites pas la vérité aux gens parce que
selon l'âge selon le mois où vous êtes
né dans l'année et ben il y a des gens
qui feront de toute façon
systématiquement 44 ans et vous n'y
pouvez rien c'est les mathématiques qui
s'imposent voilà pourquoi ce système
illisible inégalitaire j'aurais souhaité
monsieur le ministre vous proposez
quelque chose de plus juste qui
n'entendent pas les finances non plus
parce qu'il faut faire attention que
chaque disposition quand vous dites ah
bah c'est facile on va faire que 43 ans
sauf que derrière il y a une addition à
payer et je préfère je préfère quand
même puisque nous avons une réforme
budgétaire où il faut combler des
déficitifs et non pas les creuser je
préfère qu'on consacre plutôt à des
mesures de solidarité les maires de
famille plutôt qu'à ses bornes d'âge
relativement inégalitaire il n'empêche
que certaines dispositions étaient
prises certaines proposition avancée par
madame la Première ministre donc il
incompte bien entendu au gouvernement de
les confirmer mais en attendant je pense
que on peut voter certaines dispositions
par forcément d'autres voilà où je
voulais en venir en sachant que j'avais
encore donc un avis toujours de sagesse
mais vous l'avez compris et je pense que
je donnerai plutôt un avis défavorable
donc sur la durée d'âge parce que pardon
oui la durée d'âge est 43 ans
systématiquement je pense qu'il faut pas
aller dans cette voie là parce qu'on ne
dit pas la vérité aux Français mais
c'est le ministre qui dira comment il
veut faire derrière bien entendu par
contre en ce qui concerne les bornes
d'âge bon qu'il y ait trois ou carbone
on voit bien qu'on peut les régler on
n'est pas obligé de mettre 16 18 20 21
parce que je pense qu'il aurait été plus
simple de mettre de 17 19 21 peu importe
je n'ai pas trouvé la solution vous
l'avez pas trouvé vous m'avez dit mais
sachons nous retrouver peut-être
là-dessus pour dire la vérité et
répondre au problème des personnes ne
ratons pas la cible la cible c'est ce
qu'on commençait tôt et que une carrière
pénible ne ratons pas la cible et puis
j'ai aussi à donner un avis favorable
bien sûr à l'amendement de Monsieur le
Ministre parce que il a l'argile la
solidarité à travers les trimestres pris
en compte par les avpf ou l'AVA et c'est
une mesure qu'on attendait parce qu'il
faut quand même un peu plus de
solidarité dans ce dispositif carrière
longue et j'ai également à vous dire que
l'amendement de la commission
2128 donc celui que je vous ai proposé
a été corrigé pour le rang compatible
avec les amendements 45 1918 et 3407
c'est bien cela merci pardonnez-moi
d'avoir été trop long mais il va falloir
il fallait un peu expliquer cela
monsieur le rapporteur si j'ai bien
suivi et sans être excessivement
formaliste c'est un avis de sagesse sur
le les trois identiques 45 19 18 et 34
07 et favorable sur du gouvernement et
défavorable sur tous les autres merci
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur a été très clair sur le
dispositif carrière longue qui est
extrêmement complexe tout le monde tout
le monde a pu le voir je voudrais
simplement commencer par une deux
précisions de méthode à l'attention de
madame pensemonge vous avez dit madame
la sénatrice que le gouvernement avait
déposé deux amendements sur les
carrières longues pour être tout à fait
exact le gouvernement a déposé le mardi
soir de la deuxième semaine de débat un
amendement identique aux amendements 45
1918 et 3407 visant à autoriser la
création d'une quatrième borne d'âge
ensuite à l'occasion du débat du
vendredi a été évoqué des pistes de
travail sur la question de la durée de
cotisation mais aucun amendement n'a été
déposé la deuxième précision que je veux
apporter concerne un propos que vous
avez eu toujours sur la méthode où vous
nous avez dit Madame
puisque c'était déposé dans le cadre du
47 tiréol le gouvernement aurait pu le
mettre dans le texte ce n'est pas le cas
ce n'est pas le cas puisque l'article
47-1 de la Constitution et la loi
organique qui le décline disent que le
gouvernement cadre de d'impossibilité
d'une des assemblée à aller au bout de
l'examen du texte transmet à l'autre
assemblée son projet de loi initiale
auquel il peut ajouter les amendements
de son choix mais à condition que ces
amendements étaient adoptés par
l'Assemblée saisie du texte dans la
mesure où l'amendement déposé le mardi
je parle de l'identique aux 45 1918 et
34 07 était déposé à l'article 8 que
l'Assemblée nationale n'a jamais
examinée n'a pas été adopté et donc le
47 terrain interdit au gouvernement de
le mettre dans le texte qu'il vous a
qu'il vous a transmis sur les différents
amendements il y a un propos général que
je veux faire avant de donner un avis
pour chacun en essayant d'être aussi
méthodique que la présidente de séance
le souhaite
[Musique]
sans aucune
autre condition que d'atteindre 43 ans
nous sommes sur un coup qui est très
supérieur à un milliard et demi d'euros
et enfin si nous disons c'est ce que
disent les amendements qui arrivent à la
fin de l'allias pardonnez-moi j'en ai
oublié le numéro les trois moments 3103
et 3126 qui consiste à dire par rapport
à la situation existante où il y a trois
critères cumulatifs le fait d'avoir
tricoté cinq trimestres pendant une
borne d'âge le fait d'avoir atteint un
âge spécifique d'ouverture des droits et
le fait de se dispenser du troisième
critère qui est celui d'une durée de
cotisation nous sommes sur un coût qui
est supérieur à 300 millions d'euros
c'est l'état d'esprit de ce qui avait
été discuté le vendredi en fin
d'après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale et
donc pour ces raisons là j'appelle le
Sénat à faire preuve de beaucoup
d'attention parce que nous avons souvent
évoqué la nécessité de retrouver
l'équilibre budgétaire et donc financier
du système de retraite et l'addition des
mesures votées je pense par exemple à la
mesure extrêmement utile j'ai de
l'analyse favorable concernant la
surcote qui représente elle aussi 300
millions d'euros font que cette
perspective d'équilibre s'éloignerait en
2030 et je pense qu'il serait
extrêmement négatif d'avoir une réforme
qui permet d'améliorer les choses mais
qui ne nous permettent pas d'atteindre
l'équilibre en 2030 pour en venir aux
différents avis sur l'amendement 43 34
de madame assassy qui supprime les trois
bornes d'âge la vie est défavorable pour
des raisons budgétaires que je viens
d'évoquer nous serions extrêmement ça
serait extrêmement coûteux pour
l'amendement de Madame poncer mange le
36 88 pour les mêmes raisons budgétaires
c'est un avis qui est défavorable pour
l'amendement numéro 26 35 de Madame
Lubin là aussi les raisons budgétaires
que j'ai évoquées nous amène à donner un
avis défavorable et ce d'autant plus que
les différentes évolutions et notamment
le fait de une borne d'âge à 21 ans tel
que nous le proposons est tel que je le
soutiendrai dans un instant répondre à
très largement à votre préoccupation pas
entièrement mais assez largement sur les
amendements 45 1918 et 34 07 de Monsieur
Cabanel yakovelli de Madame ponce la vie
est favorable puisqu'il s'agit de
permettre la création d'une quatrième
borne d'âge et le gouvernement s'est
engagé la créer une borne d'âge à 21 ans
pour l'amendement 208 de Madame Müller
Brown il n'a pas été défendu merci
madame la Présidente pour l'amendement
il a été il est présenté il a été
indiqué Monsieur il a été il est il est
dans le dans le Lot
il est parti il est parti il n'est pas
tombé ça ne change malheureusement pas
la vie défavorable pour les raisons
budgétaires que j'ai évoqué je ferai
attention à écouter la présidence des
sciences plutôt que la présidente de la
commission désormais pour
l'amendement 4336 présenté par Madame
assassin c'est une demande de retrait
madame la Présidente SSI
c'est une demande de retrait pour Madame
la présentatie sur le 43 36 parce qu'en
fait avec le 43 36 je pense que vous
n'atteignez pas l'objectif que vous
cherchez la disposition telle qu'elle
est dans le projet de loi permet
d'intégrer ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui les trimestres cotisés soit
au titre de l'assurance vieillesse
parent foyer une partie des congés
parentaux soit au titre de la source de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les aidants
d'intégrer cette trimestre dans ce
retenu pour calculer le droit des
parents anticipé carrière longue et je
pense que c'est un progrès je propose
avec amendement du Gouvernement
d'élargir ce progrès du régime général à
tous les régimes et votre amendement
supprimerait la possibilité de compter
ses trimestre d'aidant ou de parents au
foyer dans l'éligibilité au dispositif
carrière longue donc c'est retraits ou
défavorables l'amendement du
Gouvernement c'est évidemment un avis
favorable l'amendement 21-28 de Monsieur
Savary favorable le 35 80 de Madame
ponce défavorable pour des raisons
budgétaires le 21 29 de Monsieur Savary
favorable l'amendement de madame
nécessitent et pardonnez-moi madame la
Présidente c'est la même mécanique donc
c'est la même demande de retrait
l'amendement 21 30 de Monsieur Savary
c'est un avis favorable les amendements
31 03 et 37 26 des messieurs Cabanel et
Chassin sur les questions durée de
cotisation c'est le sens des discussions
que nous avons eu le vendredi à
l'Assemblée nationale avec cette
difficulté budgétaire du coup à 300
millions d'euros et la nécessité je
crois de trouver dans le cadre des
étapes suivantes du débat parlementaire
je pense notamment la commission mixte
paritaire l'équilibre financier donc à
ce stade ne souhaitons pas dégrader les
équilibres financiers du système à la
sortie de l'examen du texte au Sénat
c'est une demande de retrait même si le
débat doit se poursuivre pour
l'amendement de Madame Lubin le 30 99
les raisons budgétaires m'amènent à
donner un avis défavorable et enfin
sur le 33 92 et le 34 08 c'est une
demande de retrait pour les mêmes
raisons que celle que j'ai évoqué il y a
un instant
question de vote sur Madame Lubin
tout d'abord monsieur le rapporteur
et Monsieur le Ministre d'ailleurs vous
parlez tout le temps de contraintes
budgétaires c'est bien la preuve on a
déjà dit mais je vais quand même le
répéter c'est bien la preuve que le
véhicule
législatif n'est pas le bon
non mais non parce que justement on ne
peut pas aborder toutes les questions de
des salariés qui arrivent en fin de
carrière
et qui ont du mal à terminer leur
carrière à ceux qui travaillent depuis
longtemps on ne peut l'aborder que sous
le prisme budgétaire puisqu'on est dans
une loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale or il faudrait aller bien
au-delà vous avez dit d'ailleurs j'ai
noté monsieur le rapporteur vous avez eu
l'expression il ne faut pas rater la
cible et oui nous y voilà parce que la
cible de ce projet de loi c'est bien les
travailleurs de longue durée si si c'est
bien là c'est bien ça le problème ce
projet de loi vous nous avez
suffisamment reproché la réforme
Touraine qui rajoute qui a amené à 43
ans de cotisations à partir de l'année
fallait-il vraiment puisqu'effectivement
tous ceux qui sont nés à partir de
l'année 73 devront travailler 43 ans
fallait-il vraiment aller chercher les
autres qui sont ceux qui travaillent
forcément depuis le plus longtemps donc
vous parlez de rater la cible on est
justement en plein dans la cible et ce
projet de loi ne la rate pas de cible
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
ensuite un détail il faut dire la vérité
donc les 43 ans ça peut effectivement en
fonction du moment où on est né de plus
être 43 mais 44 mais dans le projet de
loi aussi je citer un exemple moi je
suis né en 1963 je vais avoir 62 ans
donc en
je vais avoir 62 ans en 2025 donc il me
faudra après 62 ans et 9 mois sauf que
je suis née en juillet ah dommage donc
62 ans et 9 mois je peux pas les avoir
l'année 2025 je crois que j'attends de
l'année 2026 et donc en fait c'est un an
de plus pour moi c'est pas grave mais
pour mes copines de l'agroalimentaire
qui est viscères à des canards dans les
Landes je peux vous dire c'est pas
marrant du tout
[Applaudissements]
je viens de vous appeler
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
rejoins
sur rejoindre la difficulté de monsieur
le rapporteur
a éclairer notre choix je crois que ce
que cela montre c'est la difficulté
effectivement d'atténuer la brutalité de
cette réforme quoi parce qu'elle est
évident que pour les départs anticipés
[Musique]
effectivement les raisons budgétaires le
gouvernement n'accepte d'avoir veut 18
milliards de recettes et n'acceptent
d'avoir que des mesures d'atténuation de
brutalité de la réforme qu'à hauteur de
3 milliards et comme il dit que c'est 6
milliards parce qu'il s'est trompé et il
a pas il a cru qu'il avait avancé à 60
ans l'âge d'invalidité permanente et
donc il a chiffré à 3 milliards cette
mesure mais non comme c'était maintenu
ça avait rien à faire là et que le
tableau d'équilibre du coup qui arrive à
zéro en 2030
lui permet de dégager 3 milliards moi
j'ai 3 milliards voilà vous avez des
marges de manœuvre budgétaire et pour
accepter nos amendements vous avez 3
milliards
[Musique]
la parole est au président Retailleau
je voudrais expliquer le vote de notre
groupe sur cette série d'amendements
et je sais parfaitement les réticences
qu'à notre rapporteur qui sont à je
crois c'est partager par la commission
sur ces extensions sur les carrières
longues
nous votre en fait on va les calibrer
avec deux principes premier principe ne
pas faire perdre leur sens à la notion
de carrière longue deuxième principe
faire en sorte que la généralisation
quasi généralisation de la carrière
longue ne mettent pas à mal les
principes généraux de notre système par
répartition premier principe je disais
ne pas faire perdre aux carrières
longues leur sens pourquoi tout
simplement parce que une étude récente
l'a montré désormais il y a au moins la
même espérance vie pour ceux qui en
bénéficient par rapport à ceux qui n'en
bénéficient plus on est plus du tout
dans le système que François Fillon
avait inventé justement pour faire face
à un certain nombre de dispositifs en
2003 première chose la compensation de
la carrière longue pour une moindre
espérance vie ça n'existe plus voilà
donc ça c'est le premier point et
deuxième point on retrouve désormais
pour ceux qui bénéficient des carrières
longues des gens qui ont eu des métiers
peu pénibles avec des niveaux scolaires
conséquents ça n'est plus du tout ce qui
a été inventé le cadre et le dispositif
inventé à l'origine et vous voyez que en
étendant à l'infini des élèves de
Polytechnique qui sont rémunérés et qui
commencent à 20 21 ans pourraient partir
à 63 ans donc là là il y a un premier
problème ce qui veut dire que on
acceptera la borne de 21 et on votera
les articles les amendements là-dessus
en revanche pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'ira
pas jusqu'au 43 invités parce que là je
considère nous considérons que là du
coup la généralisation et l'écrasement
si j'ose dire des des bornes d'âge de la
mesure d'âge par rapport à la nuitée
fait perdre son sens à notre système
actuel le système actuel il repose sur
l'équilibre ou pardon un on a des durées
de cotisation et ensuite on a un filet
de sécurité avec l'âge c'est la raison
pour laquelle et pour être conséquent
pour ne pas trop dépenser financer la
mesure que nous avons voté tout à
l'heure pour les maires de famille on ne
votera pas les amendements à 43 ennemis
très bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
explications de vote monsieur vanderg
pardon
merci Madame ma présidente j'essaye de
comprendre président Retailleau vient
d'expliquer que on pouvait sortir de
Polytechnique et puis effectivement
bénéficier du système des carrières
longues je ne pense pas que tout le
monde ici est fait Polytechnique pour
comprendre le dispositif des carrières
longues que notre ami collègue René Paul
Savary s'était vertueux à nous
décortiquer mais à vous que c'est pas
simple j'ai bien compris compte tenu
effectivement qui a plusieurs paramètres
qui entrent en ligne de compte que c'est
le on renvoie au décret le soin de je
dirais réussir presque une mission
impossible c'est de maintenir une
certaine équité dans ce dispositif or ce
que nous avons demandé nous groupe
centric c'est qu'on lisse un peu le
dispositif
alors je sais bien
ça peut avoir un coup
mais la logique la logique voudrait que
quand on part à on commence à 14 ans et
avant
14 ans normalement
l'âge d'ouverture des droits et à 58 ans
ça conduit à travailler au moins 44
années
actuellement c'est 45 donc on peut dire
il y a un progrès
vous vous commencez à 15 ans vous pouvez
partir à 58 aussi et là vous pouvez
effectivement avoir une durée de
cotisation qui n'est que de 43 ans
à 16 ans vous partez à 60 ans et vous
pouvez avoir une durée de cotisation de
44 ans donc vous voyez je peux continuer
comme ça jusqu'à 21 on a un dispositif
sinusoïdal
qui me paraît oui ou en marche vous
appelez ça comme vous voulez ça serpente
entre 14 et 21 ans avec des durées de
cotisation de 43 ou 44 avouez-vous
monsieur le ministre que c'est pas
simple à comprendre si vous arrivez à
convaincre ici tant mieux en tous les
cas je doute qu'on arrive à convaincre
la population de que ce dispositif est
équitable et effectivement apporte un
progrès social évident merci Monsieur
gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
heureusement qu'on a pas appliqué
l'article 38 sur l'explication monsieur
le rapporteur ce que même en 10 12
minutes on a été en incapacité de
comprendre en réalité le dispositif qui
nous était proposé et c'est vrai que
c'est dur et on vous a déjà posé la
question hier y compris à monsieur le
ministre c'est ce que vient de dire
notre collègue on ne comprend pas
pourquoi alors qu'il y en a qui vont
partir à 15 qui vont commencer à
travailler à 15 ou à 16 ans ils vont
pouvoir partir au même âge mais celui
qui ou celle qui a commencé à 15 ans va
devoir cotiser une année supplémentaire
par rapport à celui ou celle qui a
commencé à 16 ans et c'est la même chose
pour 17 18 etc et l'inverse il y a un
effet ciseaux qui ne fonctionne pas
parce que vous nous parlez d'équité
d'égalité bon ben celui ou celle qui a
commencé à 15 ans il faut qu'il le parte
celui avant celui ou celle qui a
commencé à 16 ou à 17 ans ça nous semble
d'une logique implacable et puis pour
répondre
aux présidents rotaïo là on parle des
carrières longues moi excusez-moi
peut-être qu'on rencontre pas les mêmes
mais celles et ceux qu'on connaît qui
ont commencé à 15 ou 16 ans c'est pas
tellement celle et ceux qui ont qui font
Polytechnique c'est en général c'est les
ceux qui font de l'apprentissage dans
les carrières sont dures avaient des
métiers difficiles évidemment ils
peuvent évoluer et heureusement mais
souvent ils se retrouvent aussi en fin
de carrière en incapacité et on revient
sur le débat de tout à l'heure ils
finissent une carrière mais pas en
activité et donc cette réforme elle va
doublement les pénaliser à la fin mais
aussi au début de leur carrière donc là
pour le coup si on peut avoir des
précisions et si le monsieur le ministre
peut nous expliquer l'effet de ciseaux
et pour dire surtout que cette mesure
c'est un statut quo et c'est déguisé en
progrès social mais ça ne l'est pas je
vous remercie
monsieur
merci madame la Présidente là j'avoue
très honnêtement
j'ai pas fait Polytechnique et du coup
je n'ai pas tout compris mais je
remercie le rapporteur qui a quand même
éclairé et détaillé un dispositif très
complexe puisqu'il y a des facteurs
multiples dans tous les sens des mesures
d'âge etc bon j'ai bien compris que si
on en restait au texte actuel on générer
quand même des inégalités et d'ailleurs
c'était souligné dans les débats est-ce
que certains doivent travailler plus
longtemps j'ai aussi compris une chose
c'est que au fond une ou deux reprises
le rapporteur nous a dit oui ce serait
plus juste mais ça coûte trop cher et
moi j'avoue que j'ai du mal bon d'abord
sans doute parce que je comptais cette
loi mais par ailleurs j'ai du mal à me
dire que nous voulons être juste mais à
condition que ça ne coûte pas trop cher
et là il y a j'avais d'ailleurs cru
comprendre que notre collègue Pradier à
l'Assemblée nationale essayer de dire il
faut pas être juste et puis mettre la
même durée pour tout le monde donc moi
je vous avoue n'ayant pas tout compris
je l'admets comprenant quand même comme
l'a dit mon collègue Fabien gay que ceux
qui commencent à travailler à 15 ans ou
à 16 ans c'est rarement ce qu'on fait
politique technique il y a peut-être un
surdoué qui a commencé politique à 16
ans mais enfin ça doit être assez rare
par contre c'est plutôt des gens qui
rendent des jeunes qui sont rentrés dans
l'apprentissage et dans des métiers
difficiles bah moi j'avoue que je
préfère la justice à l'équilibre
financier dans une loi juste donc je
voterai les amendements qui défendent 43
ans pour tout le monde monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
mais merci madame la Présidente
peut-être quelques éléments je l'espère
pour éclairer le débat d'abord de dire
en souriant à Madame Lubin mais vous
avez dit Madame Lubin c'est dommage nous
sommes dans un pays FFR donc ça donne
une connotation budgétaire je peux vous
assurer je veux manger je vous garantis
même que nous ce qui nous étions que si
nous étions dans une texte de loi
d'ordinaire j'aurais le même souci de
l'équilibre budgétaire en 2030 le même
parce que si on ne rééquilit pas le
système il ne tiendra pas et le fait
qu'on soit en PLF SS ou en PJL ordinaire
ne change pas l'approche qui est la
mienne ni celle du gouvernement sur
laquelle sur laquelle sur laquelle on
veut fonder l'équilibre ensuite pour à
la fois essayer de répondre
à Monsieur gay et à Monsieur Briet à
l'instant sur les carrières longues je
l'ai dit au tout début de notre séance
ce matin je crois lorsque nous avons
abordé cet article 8 aujourd'hui le
système c'est tel qu'il existe prévoit
de guidage une borne à 16 ans une borne
à 20 ans mais il prévoit surtout trois
critères cumulatifs et un assuré qui a
cotisé cinq trimestres avant 20 ans peut
partir à la retraite deux ans avant
l'âge légal donc aujourd'hui 60 ans mais
à condition d'une part d'avoir les cinq
trimestres cotisées d'autre part d'avoir
atteint effectivement les 60 ans et en
plus d'avoir atteint et d'avoir réuni
aujourd'hui 42 années 168 trimestres
demain 172 trimestres et uniquement des
trimestres cotisés c'est ce qui rend
particulièrement juste la remarque de
monsieur le rapporteur général de
monsieur le rapporteur pardon par
monsieur le rapporteur dit que
finalement celles et ceux qui
bénéficient des carrières longues en
termes de départ anticipé porté à son
maximum d'anticipation sur celles et
ceux qui ont une carrière certes longue
mais particulièrement linéaire sans
exposition à des périodes de chômage
sans exposition des périodes d'arrêt
maladie qui excéderaient quatre
trimestres à l'échelle de leur carrière
et donc finalement ceux qui ont les
carrières les plus difficil soit marqué
par la précarité soit marqué par des
problèmes de santé on sait que les deux
peuvent être liés sont écartés du
bénéfice effectif des carrières longues
puisque lorsqu'ils arrivent aujourd'hui
à 60 ans ils ne sont pas en capacité de
présenter si je peux dire de juste de
justifier les 158 trimestres pleinement
cotisés c'est pour ça que c'est pas un
effet ciseaux finalement c'est un effet
de perforateur et de mâchonnement parce
que il y a perforation dans la carrière
et il y a machachonnement de la borne de
départ tellement elle dépend des
situations individuelles et tellement
personne ne peut tracer un trait tout à
fait droit monsieur vanderenberg il a
évoqué aussi il y a un instant en disant
tout ça est un peu sinusoïdal en
fonction de l'âge auquel on commence dès
lors que les bornes d'âge se font deux
ans par deux ans et pas un an par un an
votre votre raisonnement monsieur le
sénateur
tiendrait parfaitement dans la seule
hypothèse ou les assurer commencer à
travailler le jour de leur anniversaire
parce que s'il ne travaille pas le jour
de leur anniversaire mais s'il travaille
trois mois quatre mois cinq mois plus
tard au rythme du Grand Frais scolaire
au rythme de l'obtention d'un diplôme
les
bornes explosent finalement en tout cas
tous les modalités de calcul explose et
on arrive à des situations où oui des
assurés vont parfois travailler 44 ans
pour avoir droit à un départ alors que
d'autres seront piles à 43 ans mais la
plupart d'entre eux seront entre 43 ans
et trois mois quatre mois cinq mois en
fonction tout simplement de l'histoire
de leur vie il y a un point sur lequel
je vais inviter si vous me le permettez
le Sénat ne pas peut-être porter trop
d'attention en tout cas pas au delà de
ce qu'il en faut c'est la borne d'âge à
16 ans puisque monsieur le
sénateurs ont commencé à travailler à 14
ans doivent pouvoir partir beaucoup plus
tôt et ne pas nécessairement attendre 58
ans sauf que ce cas de figure est devenu
extrêmement rare le départ avec mais
j'ai au bout le départ avec cinq
trimestres valides avant 16 ans
concernent entre quelques dizaines et un
peu moins de 200 personnes par an
aujourd'hui pour une raison qui
s'explique de manière évidente c'est que
l'obligation de scolarité a été portée à
16 ans en 1959 ce qui signifie que ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler avant 16
ans dérogeant à l'obligation scolarité
soit sont des assurés dans la
liquidation intervient alors qu'ils ont
commencé leur carrière avant 1959 c'est
de plus en plus rare d'une certaine
manière c'est assez statistique soit des
assurés qui l'ont fait avec un caractère
très dérogatoire et aujourd'hui ceux qui
commencent à travailler avant 16 ans le
fond dans des dispositifs généralement
de préparation à l'apprentissage qui ne
sont pas assujettis à cotisation et qui
n'entre pas dans ce cadre puisque
c'était c'est assimilé des périodes de
formation donc on est dans cette
équation là elle est évidemment
compliquée et surtout elle renvoie aux
carrières et à la construction de vie de
chacun avec un impact budgétaire
particulier c'est ce que je voulais
ajouter madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le ministre
vous avez compris la préoccupation juste
un point si on met 43 ans à tout le
monde ce ne sont plus des carrières
longues ce sont des carrières normales
donc il faut trouver un dispositif à ce
moment-là de carrière précoce de
carrière précoce ne l'oubliez pas plus
vous anticipez l'âge plus vous vous
accordez une durée longue de retraite à
ces personnes là donc il faut pas rater
la cible quand je dis la cible c'est ça
c'est celui qui québé quel métier
pénible moi à qui je pense qui a
commencé le bonheur et celui-là il est
usé quand même au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années c'est celui-là qu'il
faut essayer de cibler et ben c'est trop
compliqué
et ben le système qui est proposé
actuellement qui se base sur la même
philosophie gomme certaines injustices
effectivement par rapport à mais ne les
gommes pas tous mais il engomme un petit
peu c'est pour ça que je demandais à
Monsieur le Ministre d'essayer de revoir
de créer un dispositif qui est en gomme
encore plus c'est inégalités et puis
vous dire simplement que si on part d'un
principe non pas que les 43 ans sont un
plancher mais que les 43 ans sont un
plafond pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite de par répartition déjà en
déséquilibre et qui conduit dans les
dizaines d'années qui viennent à ce que
les pensions des retraités relativement
par rapport au niveau moyen continue de
baisser
si on ne fait rien je vous le rappelle
et bien il faudrait il faudrait c'est
votre recette mais laissez-moi finir la
recette je suis en train de la mettre en
application
si on part de ce principe là pour
équilibrer le système et qui ne conduit
toujours pas à faire en sorte que les
retraités d'une pension meilleure c'est
45 ans qu'il faut comme durer de
cotisation pour tout le monde c'est 45
ans vous voyez c'est on peut faire un
raccourci mais dans le système qui est
bien complexe vous l'avez compris que le
système était complexe et bon on
n'arrive pas forcément à travers ses
propos à ce que l'on souhaite voilà
merci Monsieur Fichet
je t'ai vu
oui monsieur monsieur le ministre
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur c'est
Monsieur le Ministre moi je vous admire
tout à l'heure vous nous avez fait à peu
près 15 minutes d'exposé sur les départs
anticipés là là on a passé cinq six
minutes à comprendre la complexité des
carrières langues et je peux vous dire
c'est totalement incompréhensible pour
le citoyen lambda qui nous pose la
question en disant mais moi à quel
moment je pars en retraite pour ma part
je vois pas bien comment je pourrais lui
expliquer à quel moment il est dans les
cas hier longue à quel moment il a un
trimestre de plus un trimestre de moins
ou un chemise de Puche à ses messe de
moi à quel moment il peut être considéré
dans les départs anticipées en tous les
cas ça devient extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement difficile je salue aussi le
travail du rapporteur qu'il est dessus
fait l'objet d'une démonstration assez
parfaite dans la compréhension des
mécanismes et je me dis que souvent on
parle de notre administration qui est
compliqué on dit mais je suis allé voir
l'administration d'abord c'est difficile
oui moi je voudrais m'adresser à
Monsieur du soft puisque vous venez
déclarer monsieur le ministre il y a
quelques instants que vous lui rassurer
madame Lubin en lui disant que ce soit
un PJL ou un pffss j'aurais eu le même
souci de l'équilibre et c'est bien là
que le black blesse votre souci c'est
l'équilibre et en budget en matière de
budget un équilibre c'est un équilibre
entre les recettes et les dépenses et
vous vous ne privilégiez que la
diminution des dépenses vous ne voulez
pas entendre parler d'augmentation de
recettes
vous avez multiplié je ne vais pas y
revenir le dogme avec ce dogme de moins
d'impôts et d'exonération vous avez
multiplié les cadeaux fait au plus riche
vous ne voulez pas entendre parler de
recettes vous nous avez tout refusé
alors oui moi aussi je préfère la
justice à un problème budgétaire donc
tous ceux qui ont eu 43 ans dans l'unité
avant l'âge de 64 ans doivent partir au
bout de ces 43 ans nutés c'est une
question de justice
on touche merci on touche avec
cet article
à un sujet de clarté d'intelligibilité
de la loi pour nos concitoyens
il y a évidemment la question de la
justice et les exemples qui ont été
donnés par mes collègues montre à quel
point cette réforme dans l'ensemble de
ces aspects par son article 7 et sur
l'article dont on discute en ce moment
son vécus est vécu comme une réforme
injuste mais ce sujet quand même de
d'intelligibilité pour nos concitoyens
me paraît central j'ai reçu aujourd'hui
par mail comme vous tous sans doute
parce que nous sommes suivis par nos
concitoyens par les réseaux sur le
direct Public Sénat un cours mail d'une
habitante de sonner alors elle dit je
vis dans un mot près de Louhans et je
vous contacte concernant la réforme des
retraites et plus exactement sur le
début de son application pour les
personnes nées après le premier
septembre 1961 ce qui est mon cas et qui
auront trois mois de plus à faire je
trouve plus logique et en cohérence avec
l'ensemble de la démarche que le
démarrage se fasse sur une année pleine
pourriez-vous prendre en compte dans le
cadre d'une éventuelle négociation notre
première ministre madame borne est né
sur une période de 1961 qui n'est pas
concerné par la réforme peut-être
pourra-t-elle être sensible à cette
demande alors c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres mais les gens n'y comprennent
rien la seule chose qu'ils ont compris
c'est que c'était injuste donc s'il vous
plaît est-ce qu'on peut quand même
essayer de faire en sorte que on se
prive de l'injustice de l'inutile
complexité et d'un sentiment
d'intelligibilité pour ceux qui auront à
vivre les effets de cette réforme
merci monsieur le Président rénal
merci Madame le présidente moi je
à ce point des débats sincèrement et
malgré les efforts des uns et des autres
pour expliquer je salue tout à l'heure
l'explication de notre rapporteur
mais tout de même au final
j'ai l'impression qu'on vote tout en
aveugle
explique excusez-moi un aveugle sur le
coup des mesures l'équilibre des mesures
le bilan de ces mesures je ne sais rien
et ce qui m'a rassuré c'est que le
rapporteur d'une certaine façon
j'ai déjà dit je crois hier ou
avant-hier et honnête dans sa réflexion
c'est-à-dire quand il sait pas ou quand
il se dit qu'on pourrait faire mieux il
le dit et c'est une bonne chose on n'est
pas sur de la mathématique
identifier claire on peut pas faire des
sommations mais quand même
départ anticipé
quels sont qu'elles auraient pu être les
différentes propositions n'en sait rien
il y en a une sur la table on sait pas
exactement ce qu'elle coûte etc carrière
longue même combat on pourrait faire
mieux c'est pas très bon c'est pas très
bien c'est peut-être un peu moins
coûteux que si c'était mieux bon très
bien contraignant on nous dit 800
millions d'euros un milliard 200
millions on ne sait pas trop la tête
nous tourne carré en progressive ça
viendra plus tard mais pareil on aura un
coup mais est-ce que c'est le bon etc
bref moi ce que j'aurais aimé monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le ministre c'est
qu'on est un petit tableau
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait là quoi
combien ça coûte les opérations et si on
faisait mieux combien ça coûterait et
qu'on ait un choix alors c'est le choix
sur les sucres on est bien d'accord
c'est pas le choix de la réforme la
réforme est contre mais c'est les petits
sucres pour faire passer pour faire
passer la réforme mais encore faut-il
qu'on ait un peu d'idées sur ces petits
sucres en fait ces petits sucres ils ont
été négociés ils ont été négociés dans
une salle noire et là ça apparaît mais
sans les chiffrages excusez-moi de vous
le dire
monsieur Mérillou
depuis
6 jours j'écoute attentivement tout ce
qui se dit et ça me fait penser à ce que
disait Mitterrand il y a quelques années
quand je ne serai plus là il ne restera
plus que des comptables et des
financiers
monsieur le ministre vous êtes en
comptable et en financier vous êtes
chirurgical vous êtes sans état d'âme et
vous ne mesurez plus le coût humain de
vos arbitrages vous êtes perdu dans vos
arbitrages techniques dont
personnellement je ne comprends plus
grand chose mais le côté humain vous
l'avez totalement oublié en fait vous
êtes un Robin des bois moderne mais
inversé vous prenez au pauvres pour
donner aux riches et là je reconnais que
vous avez un certain talent dans ce
domaine vous êtes efficace constant et
c'est cela que je regrette
merci madame la Présidente bon encore
une fois on voit bien que ces
dispositifs sont faits pour finalement
combler des difficultés bon évidemment
moi je j'ai pas tout compris dans les ce
qui nous est proposé ce que vous nous
proposez monsieur le rapporteur et
Monsieur le Ministre ce que je pense que
nos compatriotes ne concitoyens ne
comprendront pas non plus on vous admet
toujours ce qui est important moi ce que
je retiens c'est que de toute façon tout
le monde va devoir travailler jusqu'à 64
ans ou pas loin ou 63 ans pour certains
j'ai pas bien compris le ce qui
permettait de le faire mais on vous a
proposé quelque chose de bien plus
simple les sons la loi telle qu'elle est
actuellement et les gens travaillaient
jusqu'à 62 ans comme ils le veulent
comme ils le souhaitent et puis ensuite
s'ils veulent continuer à travailler
qu'il continue à travailler et laissons
les dispositifs de carrière longue ou le
départ anticipé tel qu'ils sont je crois
que c'est quand même le plus simple et
puis monsieur le ministre je voulais
vous dire vous nous avez dit que cette
réforme
elle n'est que même si jamais elle
n'avait pas été dans ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative vous auriez eu à
coeur l'équilibre de
financier pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
l'avez pas fait dans un autre dans une
autre projet de loi que celui-là ça nous
aurait permis d'avoir un peu plus de
temps mais on comprend bien pourquoi
vous l'avez fait au bout du compte
si monsieur le ministre
trois points madame la Présidente
d'abord pour dire au président rénal que
sur les différents scénarios proposés
par ces amendements j'ai donné les
chiffres et le coût la parole qui est la
mienne quand je suis devant vous pour
dire quels sont les coûts d'une mesure
proposée par les parlementaires ça puis
évidemment sur le travail de mes
services mais je n'ai pas la possibilité
et c'est plutôt heureux de modifier les
tableaux d'équilibre et l'étude d'impact
en même temps que j'annonce les coûts à
ce micro donc j'ai dit les coûts tout à
l'heure j'ai notamment dit le coup de
l'amendement des deux amendements dont
j'ai demandé le retrait à la fin de la
liasse que nous estimons autour de 300
millions d'euros mais j'essaye à chaque
fois que c'est possible et en fonction
des éléments dont je dispose de préciser
les coûts et j'essaye aussi d'avoir le
plus de clarté dans les explications que
j'essaye de donner au Sénat la deuxième
chose pour revenir sur le caractère
complexe et beaucoup d'entre vous ont à
l'instant dans les dernières
interventions dit je n'ai pas bien
compris j'ai peur de ne pas comprendre
ou finalement je ne comprends rien
oui c'est compliqué c'est extrêmement
compliqué et je tiens à dire puisque
beaucoup de sénateurs du groupe
socialiste nous ont presque fait ce
reproche de complexité que le système
des carrières longues a été créé en 2003
et que lorsque et je le répète je l'ai
voté comme vous cette loi lorsque la loi
Touraine a été votée personne ne nous a
proposé de modifier le système de
carrière longue à aucun moment ni de
créer la borne à 18 ni de créer la borne
à 21 ans ni de modifier ni modifier les
critères d'éligibilité personne personne
ne nous l'a proposé et il y avait une
mesure de retour à 60 ans pour les
dispositifs de carrière longue mais pas
plus pas plus pas moins que ce qui avait
été prévu à partir de 2003 donc je
disais à un moment dans une explication
peut-être un peu emporté il y a quelques
jours que parfois j'ai le sentiment
qu'on nous reproche d'avoir le courage
de nous attaquer à ce que d'autres n'ont
jamais eu le courage d'ouvrir et c'est
le cas sur les carrières longues c'est
le cas sur les carrières longues et puis
enfin
et puis enfin
et enfin je termine je termine par
Monsieur Mériot je Mériot j'ai bien
écouté vos propos et vos mises en cause
personnelle je pense que c'est à peu
près du même niveau du même acabit que
les propos de votre collègue qui est
rouge il a 48 heures ça me laisse penser
que comme beaucoup d'autres la seule
chose qui vous habite désormais c'est la
radicalité et une mélenchenisation de
l'esprit
[Applaudissements]
madame Ferret
est sorti madame Cohen
Monsieur
Madame Cohen
alors nous au niveau du groupe
communiste dans ce débat là on est hyper
à l'aise parce qu'on n'a pas soutenu la
réforme Touraine on s'est battu bec et
contre cette réforme extrêmement
mauvaise porte ouverte au suivant on
s'est battu avant contre les mesures
Fillon et on se bat aujourd'hui monsieur
le ministre de votre réforme alors là je
pense qu'on peut être salué applaudit
notre constance notre combativité et le
fait qu'on ne lâche rien voilà donc
c'est mauvais ça continue d'être mauvais
et tout ce que vous nous dit depuis le
début et bien conforte conforte nos
positions les les gens majoritairement
vont perdre deux ans de plus et
finalement vous restez toujours fidèle à
la même logique c'est-à-dire que vous ne
prenez pas l'argent là où il se trouve
vous demandez les mêmes efforts au plus
petit au plus fragile et concernant les
carrières les carrières longues puisque
c'est le sujet pour ne trop m'éloigner
l'Institut des politiques publiques
montrent que le système dit des
carrières longues réservées aux
personnes ayant commencé à travailler
tôt ne profite pas principalement à
celles qui sont les moins qualifiées ou
les plus abîmées abîmés par leur emploi
donc si vous voulez on voit là qu'il y a
un vrai problème mais comme vous ne
prenez pas l'argent comment vous l'a
proposé avec des recettes nouvelles et
bien vous prenez le problème à l'envers
monsieur monsieur Durin pour un rappel
au règlement
la pensée
oui madame la Présidente merci chez le
ministre je
sais la charge de travail qui est la
vache c'est l'investissement que vous
avez eu ce texte quel que soit nos
options on peut que constater que vous
vous êtes dévoué pour la cause enfin
pour le coup je crois que la fatigue est
la lassitude vous éloigne de la réalité
de ce qu'a dit notre collègue merylou à
l'instant dont on peut pas considérer
que ce soit le plus agressif des
socialistes ici présent quand on
s'adresse à vous en évoquant la
politique que vous conduisez je crois
qu'il faut vraiment pas le prendre pour
vous à titre personnel d'autant qu'il a
interpellé le ministre sur des choix
politiques donc voilà il va rester
quelques jours de débat jusqu'au
dimanche soir notre esprit n'est
évidemment pas la mise en cause
personnelle de toutes les personnes qui
se trouvent dans cette émission et en
tout cas notre collègue merylou a
développé des arguments politiques
auxquels notre groupe souscrit
merci Madame ma présidente
et notre rapporteur pour les
explications mais je rejoins ce qui a
dit mon collègue Fichet c'est
incompréhensible à expliquer à nos
concitoyens quand on est interrogé vous
avez inventé une espèce de fonction en
escalier sinusoïde et je vais faire un
parallèle en ce moment avec la
délégation aux entreprises et des
collègues on est en train de travailler
sur la simplification des normes moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que la réforme
que vous nous proposez elle est loin de
simplifier les choses elle est complexe
et voilà pourquoi je pense que la
proposition de mamubain est une bonne
proposition pour simplifier les choses
merci alors Monsieur théma vous avez le
choix vous pouvez soit faire un rappel
le règlement soit intervenir dans la
discussion générale dans la despilation
de votre vous n'avez pas fait encore
très bien
vous aviez les deux options merci madame
le Président pour ce choix là je vais
prendre le premier choix c'est pour dire
à Monsieur le Ministre que nous
connaissons bien depuis des années donc
on peut se parler sincèrement et
honnêtement
nous fume camarades et c'est pas une
insulte quand même dans mes propos
chacun ensuite a droit de faire un
parcours de vie moi je ne juge pas je
veux juste celui dire que moi j'entends
et je sais son implication forte sa
volonté de faire avancer cette réforme
et c'est son droit le plus légitime mais
monsieur Miss il faut que accepter
également et je libère globalement que
d'autres parlementaires qui soient
d'ailleurs quel que soit le banc les
bancs de cette émission et d'autres
options d'autres opinions et les portes
tout simplement et c'est le droit
élémentaire monsieur miriou à notre
collègue mériou il a juste dit il nous a
pas cité il a évoqué la question de
François Mitterrand je crois que vous et
moi nous avons au moins ça en partage en
héritage ce qui était François
Mitterrand sont héritage il l'avait fait
part d'une vision potentiellement qui
arriverait après ne vous sentez pas
viser donc entendez bien monsieur le
ministre que nous avons pas les options
que vous c'est vrai que quand vous nous
dites que c'est la seule option nous
considérons qu'à d'autres options
par exemple le capital n'a pas été
inclus dans cette réforme là nous
conseillons notamment que là qu'on
évoque la question des fins de carrière
nous avons des visions différentes hier
notamment sur la question des étudiants
et leur posséder de racheter leur
trimestre nous avons des visions
différentes d'un emportées par Monsieur
Cardon voilà donc à ce n'est pas en cela
une insulte épiquant vous dites quand
vous demandez à juste titre vous
demandez qu'on vous respecte
vous ne pouvez pas leur répondre que y
aurait pour les autres une
mélenchonisation des esprits parce que
ça marche un sens comme dans l'autre
d'abord nous sommes ici nous sommes ici
vous le savez bien pour mon colibri ou
moi-même socialiste et non pas et les
filles donc de rentrer pas dans ce jeu
là sinon ne vous n'avons pas y arriver
vous demandez le respect c'est légitime
entendez à être soyez respectueux de
l'opposition qui porte des arguments et
une vision différente de la vue de vous
pardon merci
la parole est à Monsieur Julias
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre mais mes chers collègues je
partage totalement
ce que vient de nous dire le président
rénal et je crois que il y a vraiment
une grosse défaillance dans dans votre
projet c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'évaluation des conséquences de la
réforme sur la fonction publique et
notamment sur sur le déroulement des
carrières dans la fonction publique je
vais juste prendre un exemple il
concerne un domaine que je connais un
peu qui est l'enseignement supérieur et
là et la recherche il est évident
monsieur le ministre qu'avec
l'augmentation de l'âge moyen vous
augmentez aussi le gvt des
établissements de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche et vous
savez le monsieur le ministre que le gvt
n'est pas compensé donc vous allez
rajouter une charge financière aux
établissements de recherche et aux
établissements d'enseignement je crains
sincèrement monsieur le mise j'ai pas
fait d'évaluation que ça remette en
question les engagements que vous avez
pris ici même dans l'hémicycle dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation de la
recherche là-dessus on aurait aimé avoir
une analyse précise il va y avoir en
effet des grosses différences dans dans
la durée des carrières par ailleurs je
devrais pas le dire ça ici mais vous
donnez la la possibilité à certains
fonctionnaires d'aller jusqu'à 70 ans
est-ce que vous avez mesuré exactement
quel pourrait être la charge pour l'État
merci madame la présidente madame Vogel
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous dire que si le
dispositif carrière langue est certes je
pense y compris dans cette hémistique
difficile à comprendre le plus
problématique c'est qu'il est surtout
très compliqué à expliquer aux
françaises aux Français qui nous
regardent et ça c'est un problème de
clarté de la loi et j'aimerais vous dire
que ce qui est important pour les
Françaises et les Français qui nous
écoutent c'est pas de savoir qui des
anciens socialistes des nouveaux
macronistes touché pas quoi ont voté ou
en pavoté la loi Touraine mon père qui a
commencé à travailler à 15 ans il s'en
fiche complètement de savoir qui a voté
la loi Touraine et est-ce que ce sont
les mêmes qui aujourd'hui sont contre la
réforme etc ce qu'il aimerait savoir
c'est à quel moment il va pouvoir partir
à la retraite et ça je crois que c'est
c'est là où on a un problème et
j'aimerais vraiment vous dire que quand
on vous pose des questions simplement
pour vous donner l'occasion aussi
d'expliquer clairement pour que les gens
qui regardent à la télé les débats au
Sénat puissent comprendre tout
simplement à quel âge ils vont pouvoir
partir à la retraite en fonction de
laquelle ils ont commencé à travailler
il vous demande pas de nous dire si on
est devenu mélenchoniste ou pas je ne
comprends pas d'ailleurs comment ce
terme peut intervenir dans un débat où
on a simplement des gens qui je crois
très calmement demande des explications
factuelles sur un dispositif complexe si
c'est ça pour vous être mélenchoniste je
crois que ça dit plus de vous que de
nous
voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors on va madame pansement je vous ai
pour un rappel au règlement d'accord
oui ben l'article 36 bis sur les propos
de Monsieur le Ministre quand même
monsieur le ministre hier Me reçu
retaillot a dit exactement la même chose
vous le dites aujourd'hui bon ça montre
une certaine collusion mais ce que je
pense c'est que vous regrettez vraiment
monsieur le ministre vous regrettez
vraiment que ce que vous avez
prétendument condamné l'Assemblée
nationale ne se passe pas au Sénat et
donc vous usez de la provocation
vous regrettez vraiment
que ça soit la droite qui monte qu'elle
ne voulait pas discuter de l'article 7
choses qui n'a pas pu être démontré à
l'Assemblée nationale vous regrettez
beaucoup que une à une on va vous
dégonfler vos fameuses mesures sociales
ces mesures qui ne sont que des
atténuations qui n'y arrivent même pas
d'ailleurs pour les carrières longues
dans la brutalité de votre réforme et
puis je vous dirais monsieur le ministre
c'est un problème c'est un effet
d'optique comme dirait les médecins en
fait vous vous allez à droite monsieur
Retailleau il va à l'extrême droite
alors c'est sûr tout à fait on le verra
pour l'immigration ça le et sur les
questions sociales donc à partir de là
quand on va à droite et quand on va
l'extrême droite il y a un effet
d'optique y compris les socialistes ils
ont des positions trop radicales et pour
vous l'arrivée qualité s'est Mélenchon
donc de choses à intervé à terre c'est
transitif voilà mais c'est une preuve
question et cette provocation monsieur
le ministre ne l'attentez pas trop
souvent bien nous allons donc considérer
que
attendez pardon monsieur Houlgate madame
d'abord
madame madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues Claude
Reynal a dit que nous avantion à
l'aveugle et ça ça me fait penser à une
maxime de sagesse qui dit que quand un
aveugle guide un autre aveugle il tombe
tous les deux dans le fossé je vous
envoie je vous envoie à l'admirable
tableau de BRUGEL l'ancien sur la
parabole des aveugles ça veut dire ça
veut dire d'une certaine façon aussi ça
veut dire d'une certaine façon aussi
qu'on ne peut pas être aveugle à l'heure
actuelle à l'inquiétude l'angoisse et la
colère qu'il y a dans la rue ça veut
dire aussi que nous avons un devoir de
clarification et de clarté dans dans les
différents textes et notamment
dispositifs que nous mettons en place
alors je comprends que le dispositif
carrière longue issu de la réforme de
2003 d'une certaine façon soit devenu
par décret une usine à gaz d'où la
nécessité de revenir à quelque chose moi
qui ressemble simple justement c'est 43
années me semble simple alors on a cité
l'exemple des polytechniciens et c'est
vrai ils sont pas légion les
polytechniciens puisqu'ils sont salariés
de l'État dès leur première année
d'étude et bien il cotise et il pourrait
peut-être partir à la à la retraite
plutôt mais en général les
polytechniciens ils ont des fonctions
qui sont des fonctions responsabilités
et il reste assez longtemps dans dans
leur poste par contre on avait parlé et
ça a été évoqué à l'Assemblée nationale
de du risque de ce qu'on appelait le job
d'été alors ce job d'été des étudiants
qui auraient entre guillemets travaillés
un mois par ci un mois par là et qui
leur donnerait l'ouverture entre
guillemets à des trimestres et qui
viendrait perturber parce que c'est vrai
que les étudiants ensuite n'ont pas une
carrière pénible il faut se replacer
peut-être dans le contexte de l'époque
chrono n'est pas
[Musique]
n'est pas n'est pas déclenché
le compteur mais n'en profitait pas donc
je vais pas en profiter je termine
justement pour dire que la situation des
étudiants a complètement évolué et ceux
qui se penchent sur cette question
savent que désormais les jobs d'été
c'est une nécessité pour ses étudiants
et c'est aussi peut-être une des
conditions de la mixité sociale dans
dans l'enseignement dans l'enseignement
supérieur donc ne pénalisons pas ces
étudiants qui d'une certaine façon
auront fait des efforts et qui pourront
peut-être parce qu'ils auront cumulé des
trimestres partir un peu plus tôt
madame Ferret
merci
sur cette réforme et sur le sujet sur
lequel nous parlons depuis quelques
moments maintenant la question des
carrières longues le journal de mon
secteur Ouest-France à titré une réforme
dure à avaler oui elle est dure à avaler
cette réforme pour celles et ceux qui
tous on va dire même qui seront
concernés demain parce que pour tous ces
deux ans de plus votre réforme c'est de
reculer légal de départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans pour tout le monde y compris
pour les carrières longues et donc là où
aujourd'hui certains pouvaient partir à
60 ans
très intéressant cet après-midi sur le
dispositif carrière longue un dispositif
que beaucoup de sénateurs ont dénoncé
comme étant très difficile à comprendre
et c'est même le moins que l'on puisse
dire on voit que on a assez débats qui
ont également été perturbés par une
intervention du ministre du Travail on
va en parler avec Alex le poussin
Alexandre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé tout
à l'heure dans l'hémicycle effectivement
Quentin et bien en fait la gauche
sénatoriale dénoncé la complexité de ce
dispositif carrière longue dans cette
réforme des retraites on va en parler
dans quelques instants dispositifs
carrière longue qui est défendu par le
ministre du soft et donc le ministre du
socle a été un petit peu attaqué par les
différentes prises de parole des
sénateurs de gauche et en réponse à
cette gauchers notoriale et bien le
ministre du Travail a dénoncé je cite la
mélenchonisation des esprits et des
propos de la gauche sénatoriale alors et
bien pour la petite histoire la
gauchinatoriale notamment les sénateurs
socialistes n'aiment pas beaucoup
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce sont deux lignes
politiques différentes et donc forcément
ces propos ont mis en colère les
sénateurs socialistes notamment qui
estime que ces propos ne sont pas
nécessaires et qu'il faut garder une
forme de sérénité dans les débats à
éviter les attaques personnelles
oui on peut le dire en tout cas sur le
fond de l'article 8 beaucoup de
sénateurs et bien on dit que c'était peu
clair ce dispositif carrière longue
qu'est-ce qu'il y a exactement dans
l'article 8 Alex et bien content on va
essayer de l'expliquer à leur cet
article 8 il concerne les départs
anticipés à la retraite et notamment les
départs anticipés pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt c'est le
fameux dispositif carrière longue et
dans ce dispositif et bien le
gouvernement prévoit à la base trois
bornes d'âge à partir desquels il y a
des âges différents de départ à la
retraite pour les Français qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans ils
pourront partir à 58 ans pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 16 et 18
ans ils pourront partir à 60 ans et pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler entre
18 et 20 ans ils pourront partir à 62
ans alors vous le voyez ancien
dispositif assez complexe et beaucoup de
sénateurs dans le débat cet après-midi
on parlait d'usine à gaz écoutez le
sénateur centriste Jean-Marie van
lerenberg je ne pense pas tout le monde
ici est fait Polytechnique pour
comprendre le dispositif des carrières
longues que notre ami collègue René Paul
Savary s'était vertueux à nous
décortiquer mais à vous que c'est pas
simple j'ai bien compris compte tenu
effectivement qui a plusieurs paramètres
qui entrent en ligne de compte que c'est
le renvoie au décret le soin de je
dirais réussir presque une mission
impossible c'est de maintenir une
certaine équité dans ce dispositif or ce
que nous avons demandé nous groupe santé
c'est qu'on lisse un peu le dispositif
des sénateurs sont tristes également
dessinateur de gauche qui demandent un
dispositif carrière longue plus simple
harmoniser avec une proposition que tous
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
avant 20 ans puissent partir à la
retraite du moment qu'ils ont cotisé 43
annuités c'est-à-dire dans le futur la
durée nécessaire de cotisation pour
pouvoir partir à la retraite alors cette
proposition la droite sénatoriale et le
gouvernement ils sont défavorables pour
des raisons budgétaires ça coûte trop
cher c'était un peu à la même
proposition que le député les
républicains Aurélien Pradier dans le
débat sur la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale en revanche le
gouvernement va faire une concession sur
ce dispositif carrière longue avec la
possibilité pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 20 ans et 21 ans de
partir à la retraite à 63 ans c'était
une annonce d'Élisabeth borne durant le
débat à l'Assemblée nationale et ça va
être traduit dans les faits normalement
dans ce débat au Sénat et bien merci
merci Alexandre pour toutes ces
explications c'est la fin de ce Grand
Direct autour de l'examen de la réforme
des retraites mais dans quelques minutes
ne bougez pas édition spéciale de sens
public Thomas Hugh qui est bien reçoit
pour l'occasion le président du Sénat
Gérard lâcher nous on se retrouve demain
matin à 9h30 ici depuis la salle des
conférences pour suivre l'examen de
cette réforme des retraites très belle
suite des programmes sur Public Sénat
[Musique]